avec macha pas nous sommes évidemment
très honorés d'être invités devant votre
commission pour évoquer un texte
important un texte important évidemment
pour la pour la législature un texte
important pour le pays et un texte
important parce que c'est un travail
considérable que de toucher un certain
nombre de grandes libertés parfois
chèrement acquise très encadrés par le
droit conventionnel le droit
constitutionnel notre droit positif la
liberté d'association la liberté de
culte la liberté d'expression la laïcité
est en même temps doit un équilibre avec
les attaques que subit la france depuis
de nombreuses années désormais première
vague terroriste islamiste 95 pas très
loin d'ici
la fnac et saint michel puis 2001 qui
évidemment a marqué à une
internationalisation des attaques
terroristes
et puis évidemment nous avons tous connu
des attentats projeté de 2015 2016 est
désormais ce que gilles kepel appel à
janis mme dato ce faire quelque chose
peut-être de plus de plus confus mais de
tout aussi réel et de tout aussi
meurtriers mais ce texte de loi ne vise
pas à lutter une énième fois contre le
terrorisme beaucoup de gouvernements se
sont armés et ont armé la france tant
par des moyens supplémentaires que par
des dispositions législatives
supplémentaires mais entre le terrorisme
entre la radicalisation qui mène au
terrorisme et est rien il ya quelque
chose que le président n'a plus qu'à
lui-même qualifié de séparatisme cet
islam politique
cet islam radical qui est une dérive
sectaire d'une religion que nous ne
confondons en aucun cas avec une
religion elle n'est pas considérée
aujourd'hui comme étant la conséquence
de ce qui peut mener à ce djihadisme
d'atmosphère est ce que nous essayons de
faire c'est de limiter voire d'arrêter
dans certains cas de supprimer
l'entrisme du séparatisme
général évidemment le premier de ces
séparatisme le séparatisme islamistes
même s'il n'est pas le seul et que nous
faisons la loi je l'espère pour les
années voire pour les dizaines d'années
qui viennent afin de renforcer les
principes républicains qui permet de
lutter contre ce séparatisme dont on a
vu dans la cas de monsieur samuel pâtit
que à la fois l'entrisme dans les
services publics pop locaux le
communautarisme et freiner la pression
sur les agents publics comme la
diffusion par les réseaux
ce lien entre le séparatisme l'islam
politique et le terrorisme existe et
nous le savions confusément mais nous
savons désormais qu'il n'ya pas de
différence de nature mais une différence
de degré et c'est celui ci que nous
devons combattre alors les dispositions
de ce texte sont nombreuses et elle
concerne tous les champs dont nous
pensons qu'ils sont des chants qui sont
ceux désormais de l'expansion du
séparatisme islamistes d'abord en
premier lieu les services publics et
singulièrement les services publics
locaux pendant longtemps ou le savez
mieux que personne vous êtes des élus
représentant les territoires nous avons
délégué le service public
alors c'est bien ou est-ce que c'est pas
bien c'est une autre question mais en
tout cas le fait est que les transports
les lieux
évidemment aqualudique un certain nombre
de dispositions de la vie de tous les
jours sont transférés au privé et des
centaines de milliers d'agents
aujourd'hui font le travail du service
public sans avoir obligatoirement les
obligations des agents du service public
c'est à dire la neutralité neutralité
politique et une neutralité évidemment
religieux et d'articles les premiers
vous le savez de ce texte de loi est
très important puisqu'il va étendre la
neutralité religieuse et politique a des
centaines de milliers de salariés qui
ont un travail qui s'assimile à ceux de
la fonction publique ils vont imposer
dans les transports en commun dans l'est
dans les lieux délégation service public
cette neutralité
le nonce port du voile par exemple
puisque c'est le cas évidemment que que
qui est le plus le plus reconnu mais
aussi les arrangements autour des
horaires ou des lieux de prière qui
peuvent exister dans certains endroits
qui sont déléguées au privé il ya des
dispositions qui concerne toujours les
collectivités locales notamment un
article très important dont nous avons
fait le compromis évoqué par le conseil
d'état en lien je voudrais le dire avec
le président de l'association des maires
de france qui est notamment le référé
laïcité pour intervenir lorsque des
actes sont pris par des collectivités
locales et son contraire au principe de
laïcité
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler se
référer aux laïcité est évidemment sous
le contrôle absolu du juge administratif
et respecte bien sûr l'article 72 de la
de la constitution indépendamment je
vais pas tous ces détails et de ces
mesures qui concernent les collectivités
locales il ya des mesures qui concerne
le champ associatif
on sait tous que la richesse du monde
associatif dans notre pays est très
importante elle contribuer à la
nécessaire solidarité à la citoyenneté à
la vie de chacune et de chacun mais
c'est aussi parfois malheureusement trop
souvent constaté des lieux d'entrisme ne
se séparatisme en triste d'autant plus
scandaleux lorsqu'il agit parce que
cette subversion agissent ou subventions
notamment sur yon public qu'il s'agisse
des collectivités locales des organismes
qu'on pourrait qualifier de la sphère
étatique ou locales en tout cas public
et le l'état et donc je ne détaillerai
pas davantage ce point parce que madame
amis délégués évoquera notamment ces
questions autour du monde associatif et
du contrat d'engagement mais je veux
souligner le fait que nous renforçons
les dispositions qui permettent de
suspendre nouveautés ou de dissoudre les
associations qui resteront toujours
suspendues ou dissoutes en conseil des
ministres comme je lé fais ce matin pour
une association dans la presse relève
l'action mais évidemment permet david
intervenir de manière plus forte pour
que les ennemis de la république ne
puisse pas existé sur notre sol façon
structurée et sans contestation
le troisième point c'est évidemment là
la haine et notamment la haine en ligne
la radicalisation sur internet hébert
fois bien plus efficace qu ailleurs plus
efficace parfois dans des lieux de culte
et donc le ministre de la justice et le
secrétaire d'état au numérique aura sans
doute l'occasion dans l'hémicycle
monsieur le président ou devant votre
commission évidemment de pouvoir dire à
quel point les dispositions nouvelles
notamment ceux qu'on appelle les sites
miroirs qui est un point extrêmement
important que porte ce texte de loi est
en avance de ce que fait la commission
européenne puisque nous avons travaillé
avec le commissaire thierry breton si
j'ose dire en même temps pour que les
dispositions luttant contre la haine en
ligne puisse puisse être prise dans ce
texte de loi
quatrième sujet après les services
publics locaux étatique
après le monde associatif après la haine
en ligne il s'agit évidemment de lutter
contre les pressions qui sont faites
contre les agents publics il ya
notamment deux articles extrêmement
important celui qui relève du délit de
séparatisme et de toute personne qui
verrait pression ce service public sur
ces agents pourraient être condamnés par
ce délit nouveau de 5 ans et dont le
juge pourra prononcer l'exécutent de
l'exécution de la peine
en même temps qu'une le cul tf pour que
quitter le territoire national lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un étranger mais aussi
l'article 18 dont j'imagine votre
commission va largement par les dix
articles semelle pâtit chacun a subi
cela et puis le dernier point sur lequel
on devrait assister et qui est tout sauf
anodin et qui prendra sans doute
beaucoup de temps je sais dans cette
chambre du sénat le président larcher je
sais y est très attaché vous même
monsieur le président et chacune et
chacun ici c'est le renforcement des
dispositions cultuelle qui sont très
importantes à la fois dans l'aide que
nous apportons au culte c'est notamment
le cas de simplification venant de la
loi de 1905
c'est notamment le cas évidemment
d'ouverture des immeubles de rapport qui
nous occupera j'imagine un certain temps
et que tu es un sujet extrêmement
important et de l'autre côté le
renforcement également de la laïcité
telle que aristide briand et gustavo je
voudrais citer s'illustreront sénateur
maire de tourcoing qui est portable au
sénat la part sénatoriale de la loi de
séparation des églises et de l'état en
renforçant
1905 et en obligeant le plus possible on
aura l'occasion de reparler de ces
dispositions que les cultes puisse
s'organiser selon un dispositif qui a
été inventé pour eux qui s'appelle la
loi 1905 et des contraintes que nous
devons assumer notamment le fait
qu'aujourd'hui le miz intérieure ne
connaît pas et ne peut pas répondre aux
parlementaires lorsqu'il interroge lors
des financements étrangers on ne connaît
pas ces financements étrangers sur le
sol national un peu en ont pas s'y
opposer
donc des dispositions aussi intéressante
que celle ci avec des amendements
parlementaires qui ont été adoptée après
avis du gouvernement notamment
d'interdiction de vente de lieux de
culte sans l'accord de l'état à d'autres
états étrangers c'est un point
évidemment extrêmement important et
j'allais signer tout à fait l'article
qui nous permet de fermer les yeux de
culte lorsqu'ils sont soupçonnés de
séparatisme et sur ce point je voudrais
m'arrêter quelques instants puisque j'ai
de nombreuses questions de
parlementaires sur le fait qu on évalue
aujourd'hui à peu près 80 90 89 dit
exactement les rangs seulement
territoriaux des lieux de culte 10
séparatiste il ya 2500 ans de culte
musulman en france dont convient que 89
cents 2500 ce n'est pas une proportion
importante mais évidemment c'est 89 pose
des questions très important pour la
paix publique pour l'ordre public
et aujourd'hui le miz miz l'intérieur ne
peut faire fermer des lieux de culte que
ce deux angles le premier c'est celui né
de la loi sylt c'est à dire en lien
direct avec un attentat terroriste
encore faut-il que c'est un drame a eu
lieu puisqu'il s'agit évidemment pas de
pouvoir le faire fermer comme minority
report et de films prévoyait des
algorithmes de prédiction il faut
attendre que cet événement dramatique et
eu lieu il faut ensuite prouver le lien
et c'est évidemment le cas de la mosquée
de pantin que j'ai fait fermer vous
l'avez constaté au lendemain d'un
assassinat de monsieur pâtit aujourd'hui
alors que nous connaissons évidemment
l'expansion islamistes dans le monde et
singulièrement dans notre pays il n'y a
qu'à ce lieu de culte qui est fermé au
nom de cette disposition et les autres
fermetures de yole culte s'enfermer au
titre des er paix comme n'importe quel
le rp de votre commune que dont vous
êtes élu et si jamais
les contrôles sont nombreux et gelé je
le dis devant vous pour la première fois
si j'ose dire ce nouveau chiffre 17 de
culte sur les 89 sont fermés au titre
des rp mais ne le sont pas au nom des
discours qu'il porte et un discours qui
viendrait à dire que les juifs les
mécréants les catholiques que les
chrétiens tous ceux qui veulent changer
de religion les homosexuels sont
absolument évidemment à mettre à côté de
la société que les femmes sont
évidemment inférieurs aux sommes tous
les discours que vous pouvez dénoncer et
dont parfois vous m'écrivez pour me dire
mais que faites vous monsieur le
ministre la loi de la république ne me
permet pas de faire fermer ces lieux de
culte et des dispositions que nous vous
proposons permettent d' mainmise
intérieur de sa ferme et ses jeux cultes
et notamment évidemment lorsque le juge
administratif le confirmera comme c'est
souvent le cas
comme c'est quasiment toujours le cas
comme c'est toujours le cas d'ailleurs
du plus je suis mise à l'intérieur
puisque je voudrais saluer la justice
administrative qui accompagnent
évidemment les décisions administratives
dans leur proportionnalité et donc je
veux dire au sénat qu'indépendamment de
ne sans doute nos différences
importantes
il manque vraiment des dispositions qui
permettent à la police de l'ordre public
au ministre de l'intérieur pour répondre
aux interrogations nombreuses que les
représentants de la nation pause hormis
de l'intérieur et à la un moment où la
loi sera promulguée par le président de
la république monsieur président et
demandant avec madame la ministre aux
services du ministère de l'intérieur de
préparer en même temps les décrets
d'application nous nous sommes tout à
fait prêts évidemment à partager la
rédaction et la lecture en séance
je ferai organisée par les services du
ministère de l'intérieur le contrôle au
nom de la loi nouvelle et des
dispositions corps a bien voulu doter le
parlement le ministère de l'intérieur
des 89 de culte séparatistes dans les
semaines qui suivront
parce que si un acquis sont soupçonnés à
tort elles doivent être rangés dans la
catégorie évidemment des lieux de culte
qui doivent tout à fait pouvoir vivre
leur religion comme ils l'entendent
c'est une liberté tout à fait
fondamental est que nous devons
absolument respectés et dans l'autre
temps aucun français ne peut comprendre
que de puissions dire qu'il ya 89 de
culte séparatistes ne pas les faire
fermer se séparait de tel ou tel
responsable religieux
ou de tel ou tel responsable
d'association cultuelle et ce plan
d'action qui est un plan de réaction de
la république vis-à-vis de la paix
publique vise à la fois bien sûr à
protéger l'intégralité de ce qu'ils
croient n'oublions pas que des musulmans
sur les premiers à être les victimes
dans le monde de la barbarie islamiste
on a vu ce que donnait ces islamistes
ans qu'ils étaient en responsabilité
politique et bien sûr de respecter les
règles de la république qui vise
évidemment à se protéger
dans ce contexte si dangereux que nous
connaissons voilà ce que je veuille en
quelques mots monsieur le président on
les sent peut-être à la ministre le soin
de se développer à la fois la question
associative je les dis mais aussi de
toutes les dispositions que j'ai pas
voulu évoquer puisqu'elle en est si
j'ose dire
la responsable la créatrice qui sont des
fonctions autour de l'état civil
l'égalité entre femmes et la haine
contre les dérives sectaires si monsieur
le ministre
même avis la parole merci monsieur le
président mes derniers à porter et
mesdames les sénatrices mais sur les
sénateurs avec le ministre de
l'intérieur nous avons effectivement
présenté ce texte en conseil des
ministres le 9 décembre dernier à
l'occasion des 115 de l'adoption de la
loi de 1905 voudrais rappeler comme la
femis de l'intérieur qu'il est le fruit
de larges consultations qui ont été
conduites avec la société civile et
partis politiques les représentants des
cultes des élus des intellectuels des
associations philosophique il a été
comme vous le savez examiné par
l'assemblée nationale et discuter très
largement notre objectif il est clair il
s'agit de défendre nos valeurs la
promesse républicaine de la laïcité
d'émancipation de progrès et de lutter
contre le terreau du terrorisme est donc
très clairement pour rentrer dans le vif
des mesures que j'ai un plaisir de
porter auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
ça passe pour nous par un principe
simple et concret en terme financier
notre mot d'ordre c'est pas un euro
d'argent public qui ne doit être donnée
aux ennemis de la république en ce sens
et comme l'a souhaité le présent
république et comme il l'a annoncé à
plusieurs reprises nous proposons
dans le cadre de cette loi la création
d'un contrat d'engagement républicain
les associations qui souhaitent recevoir
une subvention publique quelle qu'elle
soit qu'il s'agisse de subventions de
l'état en centrales ont déconcentré ou
de la part des collectivités
s'engageront par ce texte de contrat
d'engagement républicains à respecter
les principes les valeurs de la
république en cas de non respect la
subvention sera arrêtée et elle pourra
être reprise ce qui est une véritable
nouveauté par rapport aux différentes
charges qui peuvent déjà être existence
ce contrat d'engagement républicain il a
été élaboré dans sa trame avec les élus
et les associations via deux salles de
consultation l'une avec les élus après
avec sa collègue jacqueline gourault et
l'autre avec les associations avec notre
collègue sara el halim à l'immense
majorité des associations mises aux
intérêts très bien rappelé participe de
l'offre républicaine et citoyenne
mais grâce à ce contrat d'engagement
l'état et les collectivités auront un
outil juridique clair pour entraver
l'action de celle qu'ils entravent le
respect des principes de la république
c'est aussi le respect de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
les idéologies séparatistes vous le
savez elles ont pour viser d'entravé à
la liberté et les droits des femmes
c'est assez manifeste les séparatistes
et notamment les islamistes que nous
combattons ne supporte pas la liberté
des femmes qui préfigure la liberté de
la société dans son ensemble nous nous
considérons que toutes les femmes qui
vivent en france doit pouvoir bénéficier
des mêmes droits tout doit pouvoir être
protégés dans leur intégrité et nous
considérons que les protéger c'est ne
pas accepter pour d'autres femmes ce que
nous n'accepterions pas pour nous mêmes
pour nos soeurs ou pour nos filles
partant de là nous considérons que les
pratiques dites coutumières elles n'ont
pas leur place en france
je veux parler là des mariages forcés la
polygamie la discrimination des filles
face à l'héritage la pratique des
certificats ou des tests de virginité
est donc ce texte il vient compléter ce
qu'on appelle désormais les trous dans
la raquette avec cette expression
maintenant consumer pour pouvoir
justement répondre de façon juridique
clair à ces pratiques
il ya des années de cela la france a eu
le courage de dire non à la pratique de
l'excision au pratique des mutilations
génitales et je crois qu'il est
important que la république française
pose des barrières et des interdits
et disent aujourd'hui le nom et stop aux
pratiques telles que celles des
certificat de virginité dans la droite
ligne de la diplomatie féministes qui
est menée par le président de la
république est d'ailleurs de nombreux
pays partout dans le monde regarde ce
qui se passe en france dans le cadre de
cette loi pour se fonder également sur
les avancées qui auront lieu en france
pour les droits des femmes pour les
exporter et il travaillait également
dans leur propre pays je crois que nous
devons pouvoir dire qu'aujourd'hui la
république ne tolère pas d'atteinte à la
dignité humaine que ce soit sur des
femmes ou sur des hommes et c'est ce que
nous vous proposons avec un chapitre que
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité
rebaptisé est nommé respect des droits
des personnes et égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes dans ce chapitre
nous veillons donc à l'égalité de
traitement entre les héritiers
si vous avez pas mal de questions
d'intervention sur sur ce sujet notre
but c'est très simplement que les filles
ne puisse plus être déshérités comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
eu égard à des failles dans le droit
international je vois la remercie le
garde des sceaux notamment pour son
engagement très fort vis-à-vis de cette
mesure l'assemblée nationale a
d'ailleurs enrichi le texte à cet égard
eu égard aux recommandations qui ont été
partagées par l'ordre des notaires
nous instaurons dans ce texte également
une réserve générale de polygamie pour
la délivrance et pour le renouvellement
des titres de séjour
nous affirmons que les hommes de
nationalité étrangère qui sont coupables
de polygamie n'ont rien à faire dans
notre pays et nous souhaitons en
cohérence un accompagnement et un examen
individuel dans le cadre du
renouvellement du titre de séjour pour
les femmes qui subissent cette situation
de polygamie et qui se verrait aux mises
en danger par les actions que j'ai cités
nous voulons ensuite interdire aux
professionnels de santé et d'établir des
certificats de virginité les
professionnels qui ont des yeux ronds
seront passibles de poursuites pénales
j'ai entendu différents débats
différentes interventions mais je veux
être très clair il nous sans que ce
n'est pas en produisant des certificats
la virginité qu'on va mieux protéger les
jeunes filles il ya des certains une
grande majorité des gynécologues sont
très engagés et soutiennent cette mesure
une petite minorité s'était exprimé en
disant oui mais qu'est ce qui se passe
pour la jeune fille quand elle rentre
chez elle sans son certificat de
virginité
nous nous demandons ce qui se passe pour
la jeune fille qui rentre chez elle avec
son certificat de virgin
dès sa dignité de personne ne va
probablement pas être respecté dans la
suite de ce mariage qui est démarre par
un test de virginité
donc il nous semble important de
protéger les jeunes filles qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables aux
pressions séparatiste l'assemblée
nationale a souhaité à cet égard
introduire une incrimination spécifique
des personnes qui incite vous qu'on
traîne une femme a sollicité ce
certificat de virginité avec un quantum
de peine cohérent nous aurons l'occasion
je crois d'en débattre et de débats de
cette interdiction je crois savoir que
nous devons vous souhaitez que nous
soyons particulièrement attentifs à
cette mesure et je crois que l'écriture
de notre droit c'est aussi l'écriture de
la défense des femmes et qu'elle est
fondamentale nous allons renforcer de la
même manière la lutte contre les
mariages forcés en rendant obligatoire
la saisine du procureur de la république
par l'officier d'état civil en cas de
doute sérieux persistant sur le
consentement d'un des deux époux
d'ailleurs les élus locaux que nous
avons rencontrés et notamment
l'association des maires de france
qu'avec mes sionisme l'intérieur nous
avons reçu nous ont fait part du fait
que les élus sont souvent démunis face
aux situations de mariage forcé car la
loi ne leur donne pas les moyens à
l'heure actuelle d'agir véritablement et
c'est ce que nous ferons avec cette fois
bien sûr toutes ces dispositions elles
devront s'accompagner d'actions fortes
de politiques publiques la loi n est pas
en compte at war ne se suffit pas à
elle-même nous avons déjà commencé à
travailler sur des politiques
interministériel y compris de soutien
vis-à-vis des élus locaux qui viennent
soutenir la mise en oeuvre de ce que
nous allons je l'espère discuter et que
vous allez je l'espère voter et enfin je
voudrais appeler votre attention sur le
fait que les mises à l'intérieur gérald
darmanin et moi même nous avons déposé
deux amendements très avec notre
collègue ministre de la transformation
publics pour renforcer les questions de
laïcité dans le service public
notre premier amendement il a prévu de
former à la laïcité tous les agents
publics je crois que les événements de
ces derniers mois nous ont montré qu'il
y avait un manque criant et je sais que
le sénat y est particulièrement attachée
et attentif et le second il vise à créer
un vrai
un vrai maillage territorial de
référents laïcité dans toutes les
administrations publiques l'assemblée
nationale les a accueillis favorablement
je crois que ce sont de bonnes mesures
très concrètes et j'espère que vous en
partagerez la volonté la laïcité c'est
le ciment de notre république et je
crois qu'elle doit être au coeur du
service public et je sais que le sénat
en tout cas il est particulièrement
attentif pourrais vous dire pour
conclure que je sais le travail
important que vous avez commencé à mener
au sénat notamment travers des auditions
et à travers un travail que vous avez
mené par delà et précédent les débats
autour de cette fois et je ne doute pas
que nos débats vont améliorer encore ce
projet loi mesdames les sénatrices et
mais sur les sénateurs je crois que
c'est un projet loi équilibrée qui
préserve un certain nombre d' équilibre
notamment de liberté raisonnable et
surtout concrets qui a pour but de
véritablement d'apporter des réponses
aux acteurs de terrain et singulièrement
aux élus locaux
je pense là notamment à la question du
contrat d'engagement républicain qui
nous a été demandé par des élus qui à
l'heure actuelle quand ils veulent le
mettre en place sont parfois attaquer en
justice ou menacés victime de certaines
pressions communautaires je pense que
nous sommes là en train de créer des
outils qui vont véritablement leur
permettre de mieux agir sur le terrain
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci madame la ministre bien je vais
m'attarder la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs madame lesage brignoles où
je n'ai pas pour longtemps
le temps qu'il vous faut voilà merci
monsieur milices merci madame et mist de
vos propos vous avez rappelé l'un et
l'autre le contexte dans lequel ce
projet de loi arrive au sénat
vous avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
le contexte très compliqué que nous
vivons tous ensemble alors avec
honnêteté c'est ce que nous vivons avec
sept islamistes cet islam politique nous
le vivons pas depuis huit jours c'est
quelque chose qu'il sait distiller dans
notre pays puis vingtaine d'années il
faut vraiment avoir l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de le dire
sauf qu'aujourd'hui effectivement en
tout cas l'heure n'est plus aux
tergiversations mais à l'action j'ai
envie voilà je pense que on peut aussi
partager avec vous un certain nombre de
constats qui fait en sorte qu'ils font
en sorte qu'aujourd'hui cette nation se
fracture et je voudrais vous poser des
questions en fait qu à vous interroger
sur deux choses sur ce texte
effectivement avec ma collègue nous y
travaillons beaucoup nous en sommes déjà
une cinquantaine d'heures d'audition
donc effectivement on y travaille
beaucoup
moi je suis interpellé par le texte
parce que je ne pars le titre pardon
parce que je ne suis pas sûr que pour
nos concitoyens ce titre soit très
révélateur de ce que vous voulez faire
sincèrement
alors peut-être que pour vous et pour
nous ça peut paraître clair mais pour
les habitants de ce pays
je ne suis pas sûr que le titre veuille
dire grand chose dans le combat que nous
avons à mener
je ne dis pas qu'il ne veut rien dire le
titre mais dans le combat que nous avons
à mener
vous avez par des monsieurs mini c'est
madame ministre de laïcité il apparaît
pas beaucoup ce mot laïcité dans ce
texte
et je pense que vous avez comme moi pris
connaissance de l'article du point ce
matin qui peut quand même nous faire
peur aux uns et aux autres
sur ce que pensent aujourd'hui une
partie des lycéens de la laïcité
je pense qu'on ne peut pas ne pas
s'interroger sur cet article
et sur cette enquête qui s'est passé ce
matin et justement pour en revenir au
contrat républicain dont vous parlez qui
me paraît une bonne chose il ya
d'ailleurs des villes des régions des
départements qui n'ont déjà fait singh
qui ont déjà fait signer ce type de
document mais là effectivement il
conforte les choses le mot laïcité
n'apparaît jamais dans ce contrat
républicain
c'est un petit peu dommage parce que la
laïcité elle et émancipatrice elle et
intégratrice elle est porteur d'espoir
et du coup elle n'apparaît pas du tout
que ce mode n'apparaît pas je voudrais
aussi parler de la fermeture des lieux
de culte vous avez monsieur ministre
rappeler qu'effectivement vous vous
donner des outils pour fermer des lieux
de culte on peut s'interroger aussi sur
la nécessité de fermer des lieux de
culte pourquoi pas définitivement et ça
c'est pas prévu
est ce qu'il ne serait pas intéressant
de fermer définitivement des lieux sous
des valeurs avec vraiment des contextes
de discours qui portent atteinte à la
notre démocratie j'en veux dire parce
que ça va jusque là ça c'est pas prévu
est ce qu'il ne serait pas possible de
le prévoir il y a eu aussi rajouté un
article à l'assemblée sur la neutralité
des élus à titre personnel j'y suis très
attaché pourquoi ne vous n'êtes pas allé
plus loin sur la neutralité des élus
dans le cas de leurs fonctions je
rappelle bien de la carne leurs
fonctions c'est une question en tout cas
qui peut être intéressant de se poser et
dernière question et dernière analyse
aurez vous les moyens aurez vous les
moyens pour mettre en place tous ses
objectifs que vous fixez que nous
pouvons évidemment partagé mais qui va
demander beaucoup de moyens humains et
financiers pour y arriver
certes en huit jours certes ça prendra
du temps mais les moyens sont
nécessaires
merci madame madame berberian merci
beaucoup alors quelques questions alors
monsieur le ministre tout d'abord
sur la fermeture administrative des
lieux de culte effectivement aujourd'hui
vous l'avez dit c'est soit parce que c
est harper soit c'est parce que cécile
était donc c'est contre le terrorisme
comment est ce qu'on arrive à assurer
l'équilibré en fermant un lieu de culte
aujourd'hui entre maintien de l'ordre
public et atteinte à la liberté de
conscience et au libre exercice des
cultes et par ailleurs vous disiez vous
ne disposiez pas de moyens pour fermer
les lieux de culte c'est vrai mais il
existe déjà l'article 35 de la loi de
1905 qui permet pour le coup de punir le
ministre du culte qui provoquerait a
résisté à l'exécution des lois ou aux
actes légaux de l'autorité publique
est-ce que cet article 35 vous l'avez
vous avez eu l'occasion de le faire
jouer puisque c'était une façon
finalement d'attaquer la tête du lieu de
culte qui pourrait déjà être utilisées
donc sans passé ni par sylt ni par le
problème des rp ensuite autre question
sur le les contraintes administratives
et comptables de cons mais aude 1901 qui
aurait une activité cultuelle
alors je voudrais dire que s'il ya
vraiment une chose importante dans ce
texte
et effectivement le fait de passer
l'activité cultuelle sous le contrôle
1905 et donc de faire que même les
associations qui resterait 1901 fasse
que la partie cultuelle soit
comptablement séparés et passe sous 2905
mais se pose quand même le problème des
activités cultuelles qui ne sont pas
régulières je pense à certaines
associations qui pourraient organiser
des messes mai mais ponctuellement je
pense aux scouts confessions n'ont pas
des messes ou des cultes d'une façon
générale aux scouts confessionnelles
aux établissements de gestion
d'activités privées confessionnelles
certaines activités caritatives
exceptionnelle qui confessionnel qui
pourrait faire une messe occasionnels
mais sans pour autant être vraiment une
activité cultuelle est ce que celles ci
devront séparés c'est ça ou pas et
comment est ce qu'elle vous le gérer
enfin là cette fois je vais m'adresser à
vous madame la ministre sur alors c'est
jeu évidemment que on ne peut pas
valider les certificat de virginité les
tests de virginité encore moins que les
certificats d'ailleurs ce que je répète
le certificat est un papier le test est
effectivement intrusif
la polygamie ou on sait bien que c'est
plutôt l'enfer dans la famille
les mariages forcés l'excision on est
assez d'accord par contre la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on prévoit pas ce que
la meilleure façon de lutter c'est quand
même l'éducation
or on se rend compte que l'éducation
sexuelle à l'école et quand même quelque
chose de très difficile à appliquer qui
a justement c'est peut-être le premier
lieu des pressions et la répression qui
ne sont pas seulement musulmane
islamistes etc
je pense que d'autres religions peuvent
faire le même type de pression et puis
par ailleurs vous visez plus
spécifiquement les médecins mais comment
est ce qu'on va faire appliquer la loi
qui va nous dire que tel médecin fait
des certificat de virginité et comment
du coup faire appliquer cette loi est
est-ce que c'est pas contre-productif de
faire une loi qu'on ne saura pas faire
respecter voilà et puis alors la
dernière c'est plutôt une remarque est
ce qui montre la diversité du travail
sénatorial puisque moi personnellement
au niveau du titre je suis assez attaché
aux principes de la république et que je
préfère qu'on parle de la solution plus
du problème mais c'est une petite
différence entre nous bien merci
mesdames alors monsieur le ministre mama
chemise puis madame la ministre et
ensuite j'aurai la parole aux autres
collègues qui l'ont demandé madame merci
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices madame là qui ne savent rien
peut-être pour vous répondre sur la
question du mode laïcité moi je veux
partager
nous partageons évidemment avec monsieur
mise de l'intérieur votre attachement au
mot
laïcité et au delà du bon évidemment à
sa valeur et à ce qu ils recoupent et
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi nous avons
souhaité étendre notamment la neutralité
religieuse aux dsp comme l'évoquait mise
de l'intérieur en ce qui concerne le
contrat d'engagement républicains pour
être très honnête avec vous on a
vraiment mis sur la table les
différentes possibilités et on les a
travaillés d'un point de vue juridique
le mot de laïcité il existe à l'heure
actuelle dans le contrat d'engagement
républicain dans son préambule ce qu il
rappelle les principes et donc le mot de
laïcité et nommer clairement au niveau
des prix en bulles en revanche vous avez
raison il n'est pas nommé dans les
obligations et dans les principes à
respecter pour quelles raisons d'abord
parce que l'association et la subvention
à une association n'est pas justement
une délégation de service public et que
faire appliquer le principe de laïcité
pourrait sous-entendre de faire
appliquer un principe de neutralité
religieuse à une association
nous avons donc préféré le terme de
respect de la liberté de conscience qui
nous permet donc de bien lutter contre
tout phénomène d'emprise les phénomènes
de dérives sectaires mais aussi
évidemment prioritairement les
phénomènes de radicalisation on connaît
bien ces associations ce qu'on essaye de
dix essais par exemple l'association qui
prétend faire du sport ou de l'aide aux
devoirs et qui en réalité fait de
l'endoctrinement et de la radicalisation
religieuse
en revanche si nous mettions le goût de
laïcité nous avons notre attention
étaient alertés sur le fait qu'il ya un
énorme risque très concrets que ça
puisse faire tomber toutes possibilités
de subventions à des organisations comme
la cimade le secours catholique et
d'autres qui ne sont pas neutres
religieusement dans leurs activités
c'est la réponse est l'alertent que nous
avons d'un certain nombre de juristes
d'un point de vue notamment
constitutionnel mais surtout d'un point
de vue de l'efficacité nous ne voulons
pas que ce contrat d'engagement
républicain il se retourne et qu'il
empêche l'état ou des collectivités
devenir subventionner ses activités je
pourrais citer aussi par exemple les
activités de scoutisme qui sont souvent
subventionnés et dont nous considérons
pas qu'elles représentent une menace
pour les questions de
de respect de la république pour
répondre peut-être à la question
relative à l'éducation aléas pardon à
l'éducation affective et sexuelle à
l'école de madame la rapporteur
dominique vergnes ans je voudrais vous
dire qu'effectivement depuis 2014
la loi prévoit qu'il y ait trois séances
d'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle dans les écoles c'est le toit
elle n'a quasiment jamais été appliquée
jusqu'à l'an dernier où nous avons avec
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans mes
précédentes fonctions passer la consigne
qu'elle soit désormais appliquée à un
audit doit être réalisée à la fin de
l'année scolaire pour voir si c'est 3
séances d'éducation à la vie affective
et sexuelle sont véritablement appliquée
nous avons d'ailleurs lancé un plan de
lutte contre l'excision l'année dernière
pour justement faire des alertes
notamment au moment du printemps et de
l'été parce qu'on sait qu'à ce moment là
il ya un risque plus fort de prévalence
de ces mutilations sexuelles ou de toute
action au niveau de l'école mais je
crois qu'il ya là effectivement une
action au delà de la loi de politiques
publiques et de contrôle de la politique
publique et de sa réalité au niveau des
écoles et vous avez tout à fait raison
de le souligner et moi je partage
complètement cet objectif que vous
rappelez enfin je suis là vous vous
disiez madame la sénatrice sa manière à
porter ça va être ça va être difficile
où on ne pourra pas faire appliquer la
loi
alors je ne partage pas ce point de vue
je pense qu'on peut faire appliquer la
loi
quand on veut s'en donner les moyens
particulièrement sur le certificat de
virginité que vous évoquez pour moi il
ya deux aspects un premier aspect qui
est pédagogique et je les assume
parfaitement le fait c'est le message
que nous envoyons nous on a vu des
associations je pense à un regard de
femme aux gammes c'est à d'autres qui
nous ont dit bas qu'en fait elle avait
beaucoup de jeunes filles qui leur ont
dit ah mais en fait je m'interroge du
coup sûr cette pratique du certificat de
virginité ou du test devient
ni t on a toujours fait ça mes cousines
mes soeurs ont fait ça et du coup
maintenant je m'interroge sur cette
pratique et ça génère des débats des
discussions parce que le débat a lieu
d'un point de vue politique et ça je
pense que c'est positif
ensuite il ya l'application de la loi
vous avez tout à fait raison la loi on
l'apprend pas uniquement pour sa portée
pédagogique évidemment mais pour qu'elle
soit appliquée et pour qu'elle soit
appliquée eh bien je crois qu'il y a
deux choses 1 la façon dont les médecins
s'engagent et de effectivement oui des
contrôles qui auront lieu la première
personne qui pourra dénoncer ces
certificat de virginité ce sont les
jeunes filles qui en sont les victimes
et les ong qui les accompagnent ce qu'on
observe c'est que très souvent ces
pratiques
elles sont accompagnées d'autres
pratiques et dans ces cas là on a
énormément de ong dont certaines auquel
on a confié une mission en parallèle du
projet de loi je pense à women to men
qui traduit les lois dans des langues
étrangères pour que les femmes qui sont
des primo arrivants puissent aussi
comprendre ses droits et sans saisir
parce que c'est souvent de ça dont on
parle lorsqu'il concernés certificat de
virginité
moi je crois vraiment qu'on pourra faire
appliquer cette fois comme l'excision
sous le président jacques chirac le
gouvernement et la majorité de l'époque
avait décidé d'interdire l'excision et à
l'époque on leur disait parfois oui mais
ce sera pas applicable ou certains
disaient mais il vaut mieux faire des
excisions entre guillemets bien fait
dans des cabinets médicaux
bon alors évidemment à l'époque et je le
dis d'autant plus ce n'est pas du tout
donc quand politique se mesure de cette
manière mais à l'époque le gouvernement
la majorité de l'époque ont tenu bon et
ont décidé d'interdire l'excision est
d'ailleurs maintenant c'est un fondement
de la diplomatie féministes françaises
et beaucoup de pays notamment en afrique
de l'ouest
regarde avec beaucoup d'intérêt ce qui
se fait en france comme une pratique
positif contre les pratiques néfastes et
communautaires qui peuvent exister dans
ses délires oui merci mesdames les
rapporteurs sur le titre dont je te
parlerai dans votre nuances mais c'est
vrai que c'est important je ne nie pas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'au effectivement
comme l'a dit le rapporteur on préfère
la solution c'est un problème enfin
c'est une grande j'ai entendu parfois
cette critique
c'est une grande habitude des textes de
loi de ne pas ouvrir la réalité
médiatique et politique en 2004 lorsque
le voile à l'école a été interdite tout
le monde sait que ces décès suite
notamment à ce qui s'est passé avec
rennes et le long mûrissement qu'il ya
eu dans la classe politique
on n'a pas dit c'était le titre était
pas apte à dire le voile à l'école
le titre était bien à des mots
compliqués dont on a pris du temps pour
soi raciste et ostensible rappelez-vous
le sujet de 2004 était plus juridique
tant le titre que politique
en 2010 lorsqu'il s'est fallu à ce qu'il
a fallu interdire la burqa dans l'espace
public on a dit que c'était pour éviter
la dissimulation du visage
brassens public et bi même en 1905 tout
le monde savait que c'était pour séparer
bien évidemment l'église catholique du
pouvoir politique
gendron fait évidemment pas l'histoire
parlementaire que chacun connaît surtout
ici au sénat bien mieux que moi
enfin c'est la loi de séparation des
églises et des tas donc à toujours
peut-être une différence madame la
sénatrice mme amara porter entre le mot
juridique dont nous pensons que madame
le rapporteur qu'il s'agit des solutions
les principes républicains sont la
solution à notre problème c'est pour ça
qu'il faut les conforter que
de te faire un titre de peut-être plus
politique les gens dans votre question
est une façon il appartient évidemment
parlement de changer les titres des
doigts s'ils le souhaitent sur la
laïcité pour la laïcité
certes le mot est quand même utilisé
plusieurs fois dans le texte mais je
voudrais faire remarquer ici que d'abord
et je moi aussi je suis inquiet comme
vous de ce que je peux lire des
instituts de sondage et chacun le voit
chacun couvrant regard des commentaires
mais d'abord s'entendre sur ce qu'est
vraiment la laïcité puisque j'ai appris
qu'à 50 nuance de laïcité mais en fin
d'assemblée nationale nous a amenés à
voir les débats parfois nous ne mettons
pas tout ces mêmes mots d'ailleurs
derrière le mot et nous nous rangeons
évidemment à la définition de la laïcité
telle que les pères de la constitution
reprenant ainsi le préambule de 46 ski
en prenant un certain nombre de vieilles
et disposition j'appelle d'ailleurs que
mot laïcité n'est pas gras votre
séparation des églises et de l'état
pourtant on dit que c'est vrai la
laïcité voilà encore un titre qui ne
correspondait sans doute pas à haut
contenu de son texte est telle que le
conseil d'état le définit est telle que
je sens du conseil constitutionnel
définit ces trois choses qui se
retrouvent dans ce texte
d'abord c'est la pluralité religieuse
ensuite c'est évidemment la liberté de
culte et enfin c'est la neutralité des
tas de ses agents et à la puissance
publique et ses agents ce n'est pas
contrairement à ce qu'on peut dire ou à
redire
la discrétion dans l'espace public ça
c'est tout à fait défendable mais ce
n'est pas la définition la laïcité
française et ce n'est pas le fait qu'une
religion doit plus adapté qu'une autre
non au contraire c'est le fait qu'on
accepte l'idée que la pluralité
religieuse existe et notamment
la liberté d'expression de ses opinions
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen prévoyant même que nul ne
peut être inquiété pour ses opinions
même religieuses qui prouvait déjà sans
doute que
le celui qui avait ou ceux qui ont écrit
la libération droits de l'homme avait
déjà une vision un peu lointaine de la
religion même religieuse montrer sans
doute le danger que représentait parfois
l'idée religieuse et pour l'état la
religion est une opinion et rien de plus
donc la pluralité religieuse la liberté
de culte et khalid et de puissance
publique et ses agents elle est dans le
texte
donc le sujet à la laïcité est quelque
part partout dans ce texte un chapitre
entier sur la liberté de culte sur
fermer les cultes définitivement je
constate d'ailleurs les questions de
même la rapporteure suivante c'était
plutôt que comment on équilibre au mieux
donc voilà tant que en équilibre
évidemment parce qu on part du principe
qu'on ne peut pas fermer des cultes
définitivement il se serait
manifestement attentatoire à la liberté
fondamentale qu'est la liberté de culte
deuxièmement ce n'est pas les murs qui
se radicalise et c'est les personnes qui
sont dedans je serai au jeu devrait
marquer c'est pas les murs qui sont
salafistes c'est les personnes qui sont
dedans
bon donc la destination du lieu de culte
n'est pas une réponse en soit il vaut
mieux combattre ce qui porte le discours
ainsi parfois ça passe par la fermeture
d'un lieu de culte évidemment
temporaires 6 mois un des valois plutôt
que considéré qu' une fois qu'on a fermé
les routes on n'a pas vu la personne qui
continue à prêcher des discours de haine
évidemment il troisièmement ça c'est un
point qui me paraît très très important
nous devons bien comprendre ce que dit à
joris présence administrative est donc
ce que pourrai mais ce serait terrible
pour ce texte connaître ou censure
lorsque je fais fermé par monsieur
préfet de la seine saint denis la
mosquée dite de pantin parce que nous
avons la preuve par deux fois qu'il ya
un lien direct avec l'assassinât de
monsieur pâtit que dit le juge
administratif
il regarde la disposition de fermeture
que propre et fait son nid à ma demande
et ilan a considéré qu'ils devraient
tous nous interpeller
il a calculé le juge administratif le
nombre de kilomètres qu'il y avait entre
la fermeture de la mosquée de pantin et
le lieu de culte musulman le plus proche
concluant que le musulman le plus proche
est à 12 km il en conclut la liberté de
culte des fidèles musulmans de la ville
de pantin n'est pas touchée comme
libertés fondamentales et donc que
l'acte prix parmi intérieur et
proportionnée ça veut dire que s'il
était à 40 ou 50 km il aurait sans doute
dû suite en raison de doutes dit que oui
le mit l'intérieur a raison d'y voir un
lien direct avec la laïcité terrorisme
et que la liberté de culte est plus
important sans doute que les
dispositions que donc il faut vraiment
qu'on fasse très attention et alors on
peut regretter ce genre de deux
considérant enfin on voit bien que c'est
ce que je disais en introduction des
grands combats liberté d'expression
liberté de culte ordre public protection
la nation s'entrechoquent dans ce texte
où dans ses dispositions et qu'elles
sont pas simples et que la volonté du
milieu intérieur comme j'imagine de ceux
qui sont en aspiration gouvernementales
qu'ils soient de la majorité ou de
l'opposition c'est pas de faire
n'importe quoi et pas voir son texte
censuré ni au conseil constitutionnel ni
demain aux qpc ni après demain par une
cour européenne sur la neutralité de des
élus et dans le cadre de leurs fonctions
c'est un débat qui nous a occupés
longuement à l'assemblée nationale ça
dépend ce qu'on appelle la neutralité
il est évident que aujourd'hui si je
parle de l'élu municipal qui est le seul
finalement lorsqu'il est maire ou
adjoint au maire à agir en tant
qu'officier d'état civil est donc en
tant qu'agent de l'état et donc à ce
titre le maire qui marie lemaire qui a
son écharpe blanche qui est officier
d'état civil
il doit avoir une neutralité bien sûr
mais lorsqu il préside le conseil
municipal il n'est pas tenu à cette
neutralité
il n'est pas officier d'état civil il
n'est pas agent de l'état il est dans
l'organe délibérant et la loi
d'aujourd'hui peut-être faut-il le
rappeler c'est que lorsque l'élu
municipal à une délégation d'état civil
une délégation de représentants d'états
il est comme tous les autres tenues à la
neutralité politique et religieuse
il n'a pas le droit de donner son avis
politique dans un mariage et on peut pas
imaginer amer portant une kippa ou une
femme
un voile lorsqu'elle marie déjean
mais en même temps il est évident qu'un
autre réalité de son temps pas que
religieuses sont aussi politiquement que
serait un élu qui aurait une autre
et politiques tout le temps et ce serait
drôle dé lui puisque par définition il
fait aussi de la politique alors
derrière ce débat de neutralité il y
avait la question de savoir si on devait
interdire des élus d'aller dans des
lieux avec des messes ça me connaissez
la tradition du général de gaulle
pourtant grand fervent catholique qui
n'a jamais communier devant tout le
monde
bon c'est vrai que c'est sans doute une
tradition républicaine que chacun
devrait respecter mais que serait cette
police qui imaginerait de pouvoir faire
des amendes au maire aux élus aux
conseillers régionaux parlementaire
évidemment parce qu'ils aient envie le
dimanche soit deux communes et ce n'est
pas commune et si je prends l'exemple
l'église catholique
si je vais à tourcoing et que je
communie sais que mon droit le plus
strict est ce que je le fais surtout si
je fais le jour des élections
est ce que je le fais en sondant les
âmes et les coeurs parce que je sais que
les élections et que je pars la victoire
à quadriller tout le monde entre
guillemets vous cogner à lévis de
tourcoing est ce que le fait en tant que
citoyen dont je crois que vraiment la
position du mouvement sera de rester
très calme sur cette question même si on
comprend qu'elle pose d'autres questions
qu'est d'aller dans des lieux de culte
pour faire du communautarisme électorale
on voit bien là et des difficultés mais
il n'est pas interdit à un élu quelqu'il
soit d'aller dans un lieu de culte et je
ne crois pas qu'il faille l'interdire ça
a parfois été les dispositions
présentées par des parlementaires
notamment la france un soumise à
l'assemblée nationale et nous paraît
important cependant de mettre ce que
nous avons pris dans le texte de loi la
possibilité de mieux condamner ceux qui
utilisent et youtube pour y faire des
réunions politiques qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs nationale ou pour des
diasporas étrangères bon à l'occasion
d'en reparler pas ce que ça peu sera
évidemment l'hémicycle comme ça à
passionner l'assemblée nationale aurum
les moyens je le crois je le crois parce
qu'aujourd'hui on s'évertue à table
beaucoup de temps alors qu'on n'a pas
les mesures administratives pour le
faire donc évidemment larmes sera plus
efficace frère fait remarquer que c'est
ce gouvernement qui a doublé les
effectifs de la dgsi et les
renseignements territoriaux et le
séparatisme est une finalité désormais
des renseignements mais on aura
l'occasion pour nous d'en reparler des
lieux de culte mais nombreux public
évidemment c'est un équilibre vous aurez
constaté d'ailleurs madame la
rapporteure que nous allons proposer
trois mois
c'est un débat que nous avons notamment
que le rapporteur de l'international
pour ce qui était de l'action que nous
voulons mener trois mois ne parle assez
raisonnable notamment six étaient
renouvelables
je dis aussi madame arabe en tort de ne
pas se focaliser que sur le lieu de
culte mais se friser aussi sur
l'association puisque nous pouvons jouer
désormais c'est la loi est adoptée à la
façon le lieu de culte que l'on peut
fermer et sur l'association que l'on
peut dissoudre ou suspendre évidemment à
l'écouté souvent pas toujours mais très
souvent gérée par une association ce qui
permet à répondre à ma disposition à
votre question d'après 1900 en 1905
c'est évidemment très important la
volonté du gouvernement c'était que tout
le monde devait passer en 1905 avec
imaginons quelques années de transition
il ya des avantages et des inconvénients
en 1905 les avantages et les
inconvénients à 1900m aujourd'hui a
quasiment pas d'inconvénient à 1900 est
ce qui fait qu'il ya une sorte de
violation de la loi 1901 qui est de
confondre le cultuel du culturel et
parfois de toucher des subventions voir
des recettes fiscales de de déductions
fiscales
alors qu'on fait du culte parce qu a pas
d'étapes séparer cas pas de compte
bancaire séparé et que les datas de
difficultés et que c'est beaucoup plus
simple de faire 1904 1905 et que 92 %
notamment des lieux de culte aujourd'hui
musulmans sont en 1901 le conseil d'état
nous a très clairement dit que si nous
faisions ça nous faisons une atteinte
disproportionnée à la liberté de culte
dont je rappelle que la loi ne définit
pas ce qu'un ministre du culte
la loi ne définit pas ce qu'est un culte
et ne définit pas même pas ce qu'est un
lieu de culte donc quand vous évoquez un
cerneau disposition des bradeurs au jeu
n'a pas souhaité rentrer dedans parce
qu'un culte nous connaissons les grands
cultes médiatique si je dire que vous
auditionnée sans doute mais enfin il y
en a des centaines de culte en france et
nous n'avons pas nous puisqu'il s'agit
d'une opinion la religion à distinguer
ce qu'un culte et se paie n'est pas un
culte
si les musulmans nous explique que les
images ne sont pas des ministres du
culte ce qu'ils sont effectivement pas
au sens chrétien du terme ne pleurons
pas me semble-t-il
en tout cas c'est pas le rôle de l'état
neutre et laïque ce qu'est ou ce n'est
pas un ministre du culte
donc nous avons écouté le conseil d'état
nous avons fait le choix avec lui 2
on peut toujours géré la culture 1900
nous le regrettons mais c'est une
liberté mais nous mettons tous les
inconvénients de 1905 et 1906 mettre les
avantages et en 1905
on met les avantages de 1901 mais il ya
1905 et donc on accepte l'idée qu' il ya
un bureau constitué de manière
différente que 1901 plus compliqué plus
contraignant d'ailleurs dans lequel on
dit personne ne peut l'arrêter condamnés
pour terrorisme ou inscrits sera fiché
dedans de ce type dans 1905 c'est une
disposition nouvelle
nous disons qu'il faut un
expert-comptable désormais parmi les
récriminations des cultes bien
évidemment le fait qu on alourdit leur
disposition de comptabilité enfin ça ne
paraît nécessaire pour pouvoir au moins
fait renaître les reçus fiscaux
j'étais ministre des conflits pendant
trois ans je peux vous assurer que les
reçus fiscaux sont des choses et moins
contrôlés dans les associations et
singulièrement dans les lieux culturels
j'ai même fait dissoudre deux
associations s'essayer fait part à
cassis ti qui le jour même de leur
dissolution concédé mise pouvait encore
émettre des reçus fiscaux c'est quand
même un peu étonnant d'ailleurs ça comme
ça et puis troisièmement il ya tout un
tas de dispositions qui permettent
effectivement de renforcer le contrôle
que nous avons notamment des
financements étrangers dans 1905 et que
nous avons quelqu'un 1901 donc l'idée
c'est tous les avantages de gérer un
lieu cultuel par exemple de ne pas payer
d'impôts locaux
moi je les associations musulmanes de ma
commune sont déjà venus voir pour
demander de l'argent public pour payer
la taxe foncière qui étaient importantes
je ne pouvais évidemment pas leur donner
en vertu de votre séparation et
emprunter de l'argent à l'étranger pour
payer des taxes foncières s'il avait été
en 1901 créée en 1905 et en 1900 il
n'aurait pas payé la taxe foncière passe
que des milieux sociaux 1905 ne paye pas
de fiscalité locale pour la propriété
des personnes
qui gère des lieux de culte par exemple
donc voila nous aurions aimé tout
bascule en 1905
le juge de qui conseille le gouvernement
a expliqué que ce serait à coup sûr une
censure nous avons accompagné vers une
disposition qui apparaît proportionnée
au convent juge administratif et je
pense que ce serait une bonne mesure et
que toulon serait convaincu 1905 je veux
ici dire qu'évidemment les catholiques
qui n'ont pas reconnu 1905 qui ont
demandé d'ailleurs même au parlement
assez rapidement puisqu'on a eu 1907 dès
la fin 2009 106 d'avoir un certain
nombre d'associations diocésaine reconnu
ensuite par des échanges épistolaires et
diplomatiques entre le gouvernement de
la république et le pape sont considérés
comme des 1905 et qui ne sont en aucun
cas concerné par les dispositions de
belles que nous présentons ici les
catholiques font partie des associations
cultuelles bien évidemment même si là
que l'histoire de notre pays
les amis alors a fait mettre un petit
peu de temps avant de rentrer dans la
disposition voulue par parra décide de
passer le brillant dernier point vous
évoquez article 35 candidats est ce que
tout ça est bien nécessaire notamment
pour la police du culte l'arctique 35 en
1905 madame la scène rapporte en effet
jamais été utilisé par aucun
gouvernement
et pour cause je vais dire à 35,6 un
discours prononcé ou un écrit affiches
et distribué publiquement dans des lieux
où s'exerce le culte contient une
provocation directe à résister à
l'exécution des lois aux actes légaux de
l'autorité publique ou s'il tend à
soulever ou armée une partie des
citoyens contre les autres le ministre
du culte qui en sort alors du coupable
sera puni d'un emprisonnement de trois
mois à deux ans jusqu'ici on peut à peu
près d'accord
encore faut-il définir ce qu'est
ministres du culte mais imaginons et la
phrase d'après ne manque pas de sel
explique pourquoi personne à utiliser en
115 ans sans préjudice des peines de la
complicité dans le cas où la provocation
était suivie d'une sédition révolte ou
guerre civile
donc comme pour l'instant aucun discours
d'eau car son sable du culte n'a mené
pour l'instant à la sédition la guerre
civile aucun gouvernement n'a plus
désertiques 35 à vous même qu'un
ministre qui amènerait à la guerre
civile et corey qu'un an
d'emprisonnement sont fréquemment une
peine peu proportionnée c'est nous qui
nous apparaît nécessaire de mettre à
jour
de 1905 sur ce point merci monsieur le
ministre j'ai plusieurs demandes de
parole c'est exactement mon nom je vous
parle monsieur jean pierre sueur
monsieur dany va doubler madame maryse
carrère su stéphane le rudulier mais
d'allier boyer madame lherbier et enfin
madame de la gontrie
monsieur sûr vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre
plus nous travaillons sur cette loi ce
projet de loi
plus nous nous demandons finalement s'il
aura de l'effet parce que nous avons
reçu les représentants des cultes comme
vous même qui nous ont dit mais dans ce
pays où finalement la liberté de
religion existe où il est clair que
l'état n'a pas pour mission d'organiser
les cultes il y à toute une série de
contraintes qui arrive par exemple les
représentants des protestants nous ont
dit mais pourquoi diable nous importons
tout ça est ce vraiment nécessaire
c'est une question qui revient tout le
temps est ce nécessaire et je comprends
bien que vous voulez inciter à ce que
des associations 1901 se transforme pour
adhérer à l'association 1905
mais on se demande en lisant le texte
quelles dispositions vont faire qu'elles
vont être incités à passer de 1901 en
voilà alors j'ai encore une ou deux
questions eu l'ordre public
il est parlé d'ordre public dans un
article relatif aux compétences ils ont
des as des des institutions cultuelles
moi je crois monsieur le ministre que
c'est vous quoi l'ordre public
les associations cultuelles n'ont pas
pour mission de gérer l'ordre public
parce que vous en pensez mais bon il
suffit qu'elles respectent les lois de
la république
à cet égard il ya une question qui a
déjà été posée par madame la rapporteure
et qui a été posée hier par une audition
que nous avons entendu il y a quelqu'un
dans une mosquée puisque c'est le cas
qui tient des propos par exemple raciste
contraire à la loi
donc il est normal que cette personne
soit sanctionné parce que le racisme
n'est pas une opinion c'est un délit
simplement est ce que c'est un critère
pour fermer l'établissement
parce que si vous fermez l'établissement
et qu'après les tribunaux administratifs
décide d'annuler votre décision
ça va être naturellement pire donc à
partir de quel moment on va dire que
c'est pas un propos individuelle et qui
comme telle mérite d'être sanctionné
mais qu'il faut interdire la communauté
disons le lieu et les participants
compte tenu que les participants peuvent
dire mais nous on n'est pas responsable
de ses propos voilà j'avais encore une
question mais j'ai déjà assez parlé
pour savoir si vous tenez vraiment à
cette histoire d'immeubles de rapport et
c'est peut-être lié une sorte
d'idéalisme qui est le mien j'ai un peu
l'idée quoi que les religions sont là
pour des questions spirituelles que
c'est déjà très très prenant 1 ces
questions-là immeubles de rapport bon
est ce que c'est vraiment l'objet est
quoi bon mais j'ai peut-être tort
et peut-être que cette préoccupation
monsieur le ministre et angélique auquel
cas il faudra me pardonner merci
monsieur sur monsieur mateu blé merci
monsieur p dang nhât sionisme ma
question se rapporte à l'école publique
qui est obligatoire gratuite et laïque
et qu'ils creusaient la république
en effet l'association de l'est des plus
jeunes commencent en son sein et on y
apprend la langue française à la
maîtriser les fondamentaux l'histoire de
france est en fait c'est en allant à
l'école que nous en apprenons être
français on a pourquoi je souhaitais
article 24 de ce projet de loi qui
prévoit la mise en place d'un
encadrement des contrôles plus fort 2
instruction en famille l'état de santé
de l'enfant des visions une pratique
sportive arctic sea des régions
géographiques à l'existence du site
propre à l'enfant mais je me pose de
question pour quelle raison 7000 semble
application si cette loi est adoptée
n'aurait lieu qu'en 2024 et quelles
mesures supplémentaires
comptez vous prendre pour aider les
mères dans leur mission de contrôle
puisque ça retombe toujours sur les
locaux et je reprendrai quelque chose
qui est venu par madame le rapporteur
concernant la suite on civique dans le
temps on avait quand même la sauce chili
qu est-ce qui a pas quelque chose de
pédagogie car ajouté au niveau de
l'école puis c'est l'endroit même où on
peut prendre les enfants plus bas âge et
ordonné de cette notion de laïcité et
c'est peut-être un peu volé qui manque
dans cette dans cette position de loi de
peut-être en rapport avec lui et
rationnelle d'avoir un lien puisque je
pense que les enfants alain certaines
âge sont plus réceptifs en dehors du
lieu familial pour comprendre ce que
c'est que la laïcité
je vous remercie si madame maryse
carrère merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
je mesure la difficulté aujourd'hui pour
un texte tel que celui que vous
présentez de préserver un équilibre
entre les libertés de culte les libertés
de se réunir en association et le
respect des principes de la loi de notre
république
mais aussi le fil du rasoir sur lequel
on peut être tout le temps entre la
liberté de culte et son contrôle pour le
groupe rdse qui porte depuis sa création
la laïcité dans son adn et je
rappellerai pas ici les travaux de les
combats de ma collègue françoise laborde
notre ancien collègue sur ses causes là
et notamment sur les violences faites
aux femmes jeu
[Musique]
parce que nous avons été tous choqués
par ce que a rappelé notre rapporteur le
sondage ifop qui est sorti ce matin où
on a plus d'un lycéen sur deux qui se
dit favorable au port des signes
religieux ostensibles dans les lycées
publics deux fois plus que la population
sur la population des lycéens 49% ne
voit aucun inconvénient à ce que les
agents publics affichent leurs
convictions religieuses
on se rend compte que là on est sur une
conception très minimaliste de la
laïcité et on se rend compte aussi que
la religion n'est plus perçu comme un
corpus de valeurs auxquelles on croit
mais plutôt comme une une partie
complète de son identité
et ça ça ça nous arrive à nous gêner
aujourd'hui et nous partageons avec le
groupe rdse une bonne partie des des
propositions que vous faites dans ce
projet de loi même si je pense quand il
manque d'ambition sur une partie qui est
la valeur éducative on paye aujourd'hui
30 ans d'abandon éducatif de cette
valeur fondamentale
ce texte ne reflète pas mon avis
suffisamment cette ambition éducative
forte en matière d'apprentissage de la
laïcité
aussi ma question elle est toute simple
quelle mesure au delà de ce texte se
rendent prévu à l'avenir pour pu pour
pallier ce manque
merci monsieur régulier merci monsieur
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre
effectivement c'est un projet de loi qui
qui répond à une situation donnée à une
urgence même de préserver notre notre
vivre ensemble et lutter contre toutes
les formes de séparatisme
gevrey souhaiterais vous de vous
interroger sur la distorsion entre les
objectifs initiaux qui avaient été
affichés et la version du projet de loin
que vous nous soumettez à savoir dans
des versions antérieures il était
question de lutte contre le terrorisme
de lutte contre l'islamisme radical
contre le séparatisme pour aboutir enfin
conforter les principes de la république
alors faut-il voir dans cette définition
différentes définitions successives de
ce projet de loin une espèce de fausse
pudeur ou une certaine forme
d'appréhension pour ne pas diviser notre
notre société et puis d'un point de vue
plus constitutionnel vous l'avez rappelé
dans vos propos monsieur le ministre le
projet de loi touche à certaines de nos
libertés fondamentales vous avez parlé
de la liberté d'association de culte
d'association est en fait en renonçant
peut-être à l'objectif initial on
élargissant le spectre
n'avez vous pas la crainte d'une censure
constitutionnelle plus forte sur
certaines dispositions et n'aurait il
pas été plus plus sage tout simplement
d'adopter la proposition de loi
constitutionnel issu de notre assemblée
pour inscrire notamment dans la loi
fondamentale que nul ne peut s'exonérer
de la règle commune au titre de son
origine ou de sa religion
et puis à la guise de conclusion mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec le projet de loin
et son examen vous avez eu la
gentillesse vendredi dernier de devenir
dans ma belle commune de rognac pour
l'inauguration de la brigade
territoriale autonome de gendarmerie
je vous sais trés trés attaché notamment
au confort des forces de l'ordre vous
l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé dans dans
votre propos je voudrais vous remercier
vivement de votre présence je voudrais
vous dire que je regrette vivement que
je n'ai pas je ne puisse pas recevoir
une invitation pour participer à cette
cérémonie
merci monsieur liste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
j'avais beaucoup de questions mais je
voudrais évoquer avec vous la lutte
contre les mariages fluo frauduleux
prévu à l'article 17
je me permets de rappeler lorsque j'ai
déposé à l'assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi le 21 février 2018
sur ce sujet j'ai fait l'objet de
d'attac
plusieurs partis politiques et de votre
majorité
lorsque j'ai proposé des amendements sur
ce sujet dans la loi asile immigration
on a voulu faire croire que c'était un
épiphénomène votre prédécesseur gérard
collomb a même rejeté des propositions
qui sont aujourd'hui reprises dans votre
texte
je m'en réjouis mais je pense notamment
au fait de rendre obligatoire la saisine
du procureur de la république en cas de
doute sur la sincérité du mariage et je
me félicite de voir qu'une nouvelle fois
encore ce qui n'était pas possible
hierle est aujourd'hui j'ose espérer
monsieur le ministre que ce sont nos
propositions qui sont systématiquement
rejetées pour être reprise quelques
semaines après ne le sont pas par
posture pâtit partisanes car à chaque
silence sur les mariages frauduleux
c'est une situation humainement honteuse
que nous cautionnons c'est une
organisation de trafic d'êtres humains
que nous encourageons nous estimons
d'ailleurs à plusieurs milliers le
nombre de mariages blancs ou gris
contracté chaque année en france
à titre de comparaison la belgique
empêche 7000 union suspecte par an
malheureusement en france ne dispose pas
de statistiques à ce sujet nous savons
que les mariages concernent près de 24%
des cas de naturalisation en 2019 contre
21% en 2010 est je le rappelle en 2019
plus de 112 mille étrangers sont devenus
français
parmi eux 27 mille ont été naturalisés
suite à un mariage avec un ressortissant
français
en effet la naturalisation concerne 112
mille personnes en 2019 dont 27 mille
suite à un mariage
nous savons également que ces dernières
années les mariages mixtes ont gagné du
terrain
ils représentent aujourd'hui 27% selon
l'insee les mariages mixtes représentait
6% des unions célébrées en france en
1950 contre 14 % en 2015
ces statistiques sur les mariages mixtes
réflète pardon les flux migratoires en
france
c'est pour cela que 37% des unions
mixtes célébrés dans notre pays en 2015
on unit un conjoint français avec une
personne de nationalité
et du maghreb 22 % avec un français yann
européen 14% avec un français et
ressortissants d'afrique sub saharienne
concernant les mariages frauduleux selon
certains officiers d'état civil repris
par certains médias les pays les plus
représentés par ces mariages varie selon
les villes et j'en viens à ma question
parce que nous ne disposons pas de
statistiques officielles la tunisie
l'algérie et le maroc sont concernés
tout comme haïti certains pays d'afrique
ainsi que des pays d'europe de l'est est
aussi notamment dans le cadre des
mariages gris encore la chine ou le
vietnam et vous savez que ces mariages
se monnaye et ce modèle extrêmement cher
pourtant en france nous ne savons pas
combien de mariages frauduleux sont
célébrés ni combien sont annulés chaque
année est d'ailleurs en tant que maire
pour ce qu'ils ont fait des signalements
moi j'avais relaté mon expérience je
n'avais jamais eu de réponse de la part
de la préfecture lorsque j'avais signalé
des mariages qui pouvait sembler suspect
c'est à dire que nous avons une fin de
non recevoir de la part du préfet en
tout cas ça a été le cas lorsque j'ai
été maire
ma question est la suivante est ce que
nous sommes en mesure de savoir combien
il ya de mariages blancs ou gris
aujourd'hui et où sont ils répartis et
quelle nationalité cela concerne je
voudrais aussi savoir si nous ne connaît
pour comment connaître la nationalité
des personnes qui se trouvent en
situation irrégulière sur notre
territoire et j'aimerais vraiment
monsieur le ministre à avoir des
réponses à ces questions je les ai pas
eus lorsque je les ai posé précédemment
mais peut-être qu'aujourd'hui à la
faveur de ce texte on pourrait les
obtenir je vous remercie madame boyer
même verviers oui monsieur président
j'ai deux questions une pour monsieur le
ministre et une pour madame
personnellement je suis très favorable à
une réaction il faut réagir
c'est la première fois où j'ai eu ce
sentiment c'était
au forum international de lutte contre
la cybercriminalité de la gendarmerie
le forum international y en a tous les
ans depuis 15 ans à lille et tous les
ans les gendarmes nous montrent qu'ils
peuvent lutter contre la radicalisation
contre la haine en ligne contre les
réseaux cyber criminels la plupart du
temps ils nous disent qu'ils manquent de
personnel qui ne manquent de deux ils
peuvent recruter des ingénieurs ils
peuvent recruter des tas de personnes
cyber spécialistes mais il faut leur
donner les moyens
la france n'est pas toute seule on le
voit lors de ces jeux des échanges de
gendarmerie ma question monsieur le
ministre est de savoir si vous avez des
objectifs européens notamment dans ce
cadre de de lutte contre la cyber
sécurité en ligne
si vous avez des pistes à exploiter avec
nos partenaires européens concernant ce
genre de lutte
la deuxième question concerne madame
cher pas vous savez j'étais enseignant
toute ma vie j'ai vu des étudiants de
partir en vacances et ne pas revenir au
mois de septembre
parce qu'elle était mariée de force et
vous doutez bien que votre sujet
m'interpelle vivement j'ai déposé avec
ma collègue bon fantine une ppl
concernant justement les mariages forcés
et pour que ça ne soit pas seulement de
la prévention mais aussi de la sanction
pour celui qui qui exploite ce genre de
situation alors voilà je me pose la
question de savoir si les médecins vont
vont jouer le jeu pour les certificat de
virginité ça il n'y a pas que les
certificats jay virginité moi quand
j'étais conseillère générale je
m'apercevais qui avait beaucoup de sous
le cadre du secret médical les médecins
nous le disait anonymement
mais il y avait des demandes de
reconstruction de l'hymen et ça c'était
très très fréquent leur demande est très
très souvent et il le faisait par devant
les supplications de deux des jeunes
filles qui se voyait complètement perdus
si elle n'avait pas cette cette
reconstruction
alors je voudrais savoir madame si vous
pensez
comment vous allez agir vis-à-vis des
médecins certes une interdiction du
certificat de 2
virginité mais il n'ya pas que ça
servier madame de la gontrie
ensuite monsieur de bellelay et monsieur
philippe bas on laissera des ministres
répondent merci monsieur le président de
2,2 points
le premier c'est que effectivement ce
texte peut laisser un petit peu perplexe
dans le sens où nous avions compris
qu'il était inspirée du discours des
bureaux du président de la république et
c'est vrai qu'on ne retrouve pas
l'ensemble de ce qui avait pu être
annoncé ce jour là alors j'ai vu vous
aviez déjà été interrogé sur ce point et
que vous y répondiez que ce texte est
une partie de ce qui était évoqué lors
du discours des mureaux n'empêche que il
n'y a rien ici qui peut traiter de
l'ensemble des promesses de la
république
or c'est bien quand même ce qui laisse
penser ce que laisse penser le titre
puisqu'il n'y a rien sur les droits
sociaux les droits économiques la mixité
scolaire bref en revanche c'est un texte
extraordinairement normatif pour
utiliser un terme neutre ce qui touche à
de nombreuses libertés ça a été évoqué
tout à l'heure par nos collègues
association conscience culte réunion
opinion communication presse libre
administration des collectivités locales
et enseignement donc c'est pour ça qu'on
est un petit peu mal à l'aise face au
spectre général et à la lecture qu'on
peut qu'on peut avoir de ce texte
ensuite une question c'était plus une
remarque une question plus précise
il y a dans ce texte un article
18 et qui va nécessairement enfin en
tout cas qui cohabitent jusqu'à ce jour
dans le débat parlementaire avec
l'article 24 du texte que vous porter
aussi ça tombe bien
pourtant il va bien falloir que ces deux
textes s'articule parce que le principe
de la légalité des délits et des peines
fait que ça s'impose à nous nous devons
avoir une rédaction qui soit claire
puisqu'il faut un texte pénal précis et
clair pour que les dispositions soient
valides
donc nous allons nous trouver demain
j'ai envie dire indépendamment de la
rédaction de l'article 24 sorties de
l'assemblée nationale vous savez que le
sénat ait adopté cette modification ce
matin une nouvelle rédaction va sortir
le périmètre global c'est que l'article
24 nouvelles formules va-t-on dire
version sénat sera plus étroit je fais
ça à grands traits que le futur article
18 n'empêche que les champs
d'application vont être concurrents donc
ma question est une question de comment
dire de voile à 2,10 d'histoire
parlementaire
c'est à dire qu'il va bien falloir au
bout du bout qu'il y ait une seule
incrimination applicables de manière
précise aux infractions concernées donc
vous êtes porteur des deux textes
comment pensez-vous articuler ce
concours d'infractions prévues dans deux
textes différents
merci madame charlotte business et merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre de questions une
observation une première question à
l'article 27 du texte le préfet peut
s'opposer au caractère à la
reconnaissance du caractère cultuel
d'une association loi 1901 qui accomplit
la procédure il peut le faire en
utilisant trois arguments deux sont très
objectif le troisième est été est prévu
ce sont des motifs d'ordre public
moi je ne sais pas définir les motifs
d'ordre public et je me pose la question
je veux la partager avec vous voir si on
n'introduit pas là une forme de
subjectivité pas d'arbitraire une forme
de subjectivité une petite inquiétude
légistique second point et avec le même
angélisme que notre collègue sueur moi
je ne vois pas effectivement pourquoi on
interdirait à des associations parce
qu'elles sont cultuel de ne pas acquérir
et de ne pas administrer des biens de
rapports comme d'autres associations
peuvent le faire je ne me dérange
absolument pas et est au contraire et
avec le même angeli je me demande
pourquoi on interdirait de l'acquisition
à titre onéreux à ces associations là on
peut imaginer que une association
cultuelle dispose d'un bien qui lui a
été donnée elle le vend parce qu'elle
n'en a plus les âges et elle
souhaiterait investir dans un autre
ça me choquerait absolument pas qu'on le
permettent qu'en pensez vous monsieur le
monsieur le ministre et enfin une
observation le un questionnaire commun à
l'ensemble des collectivités est prévu
et ça me semble une amélioration très
positif delà de la lutte contre les
mariages qui connaissent un vice du
consentement ou une absence de
contraintes ou une contrainte par dont
plusieurs maires m'ont dit avoir pris la
peine d'élaborer ces questionnaires et
de signaler au procureur de leur
territoire un des mariages contestable
pour ces motifs
plusieurs m'ont dit le procureur nous a
appelés pour nous dissuader ils ont
répondu écrivait le mois et nos
procureurs en conséquence dans les mois
qui ont suivi a systématiquement
autorisé dans le délai de 15 jours la
célébration des mariages est il ce
dispositif est améliorée à l'article 17
je me demande dès lors enfin je voulais
signaler que dès lors que le procureur
en l'espèce est plutôt le représentant
de l'état semble-t-il ça ne mérite pas
une remobilisation du garde par le garde
des sceaux
tu me suis fait débat merci monsieur le
président madame et monsieur les
ministres il ya dans votre texte
plusieurs dispositions que je suis prêt
à voter
il y en a d'autres que je ne voterai pas
mais au delà de ses dispositions
ponctuelles sur lesquels nous aurons
bien sûr nous prononcer j'ai une
question plus générale sur la proche
politique qui est la vôtre
nous sommes tous je crois ou
probablement presque tous d'accord sur
cette idée qu'il faut assurer une
séparation étanche entre culte et
politique
c'est d'ailleurs au coeur de la loi de
1905 vous espérez faire sortir les
salafistes des mosquées mais alors où
iront ils
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que la
combinaison de la liberté de réunion et
de la liberté d'expression leur
permettent de se tourner vers d'autres
lieux que les mosquées pour répandre
leur propagande
et si tel devait être le cas
quels sont les instruments que vous
proposez pour empêcher cette dérive au
fond qui ferait passer le salafisme des
mosquées salafisme des salles de réunion
sans gêner le moins du monde cette
propagande qui se répand nous serions en
quelque sorte mieux protéger contre
l'intrusion du politique dans les lieux
de culte que contre la diffusion d'une
idéologie subversive
en dehors des lieux de culte et je me
demande comment on peut traiter ce
problème je vous je vous le dis parce
que je crois que ça mérite débat entre
nous parce que on risque d'avoir en bété
tous les cultes sans distinction qui ne
pose aucun problème à la république pour
un résultat qui serait
en fin de compte absolument dérisoires
dans notre volonté de faire reculer le
séparatisme alors je ne partage pas
l'angélisme du président sueur ou de mon
collègue de bell n'est mais je dois vous
dire que je ne partage n'ont pas non
plus le vôtre alors il me reste une
personnalité qui a demandé la clé ainsi
une sénatrice madame benbassa et après
vraiment j'arrête pour laisser la parole
aux miss madame benbassa ou m'entendais
très bien
bonjour et merci monsieur le président
je voudrais poser de questions la
première c'est sur la transformation de
l'article à vannes c'est et qui prévoit
que chaque association cultuelle
déclarent tous les cinq ans au préfet de
satellites et cultuel celui ci ayant
deux mois pour donner ou non son accord
cette exigence s'ajoutent n'est ce pas
la déclaration préfectorale abus
habituel et qui est doublée d'une
réévaluation quinquennal de cette
qualité culturelle elle qui serait une
régression étonnante et je cite la
cheville de rang ce qui m'a écrit à ce
sujet et ce sont ses mots et je viendrai
à donner aux préfets la charge de
reconnaître ou non un culte en tant que
tel ce qui est tout le contraire de ça
de ce qu'a voulu la république avec la
loi de séparation
je voudrais aussi avoir plus de détails
sur l'article 4 qui qui précise dans la
loi de 1905 le préfet pourra prononcer
la fermeture administrative temporaire
des lieux de culte dans lesquels des
propos haineux sont tenues écouter un
tel dispositif existe déjà depuis la loi
sylt de 2017 et il est inscrit au livre
2 du code de la sécurité intérieure dès
lors lancer l'introduction ces nouvelles
dispositions dans la
loi du 9 décembre 1905 plutôt que dans
le code de la sécurité intérieure
interroge aimé les 13 d'être justifié ce
sont quelques éléments sur
l'affaiblissement des libertés publiques
qui affaiblissent également les
principes républicains eux mêmes donc
quel est l'intérêt d'aller dans ce sens
puisqu'on veut renforcer les valeurs de
la république
la sénatrice persie bien monsieur le
ministre mes amis je vous avais la
parole pour répondre aux questions
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
président de nombreuses questions ont
été posées je m'en vais être exhaustif
évidemment avec madame la ministre
d'avoir peut-être dire on en prend pour
être utile puisque savait pas grand
chose à voir avec le débat mais
j'entends le sénateur je regrette si
vous n'avez pas été invité mais je
jouerai à dire monsieur c'est à tort que
le sédition de votre commune c'est
madame la maire de la commune qui
méritait il me semble pour sais que
j'aurais pu peut-être partager cela avec
les élus du département surtout le le
caserne départementale appartient aux
deux présentent deux départements et je
n'ai fait qu'inaugurer un lieu qui était
départemental en l'occurrence jeu
j'aurai donc que j'aurais peut-être dû
regarder que ni la mère ni la présente
département qui passerait de votre bord
politique vous ayez invité je le ferai
la prochaine fois je m'en excuse
si vous en avez si vous n'avez pas été
pas été le cas
voilà j'en suis je suis confus et
j'imaginais qu'il y avait quand même une
discussion locales sur les autres sujets
évidemment bon monsieur sur vous poser
finalement une question qui est assez
miroir à celle du président bas et je
vais essayer de répondre d'abord à la
philosophie générale du texte que dont
vous nous invitez indépendamment des
dispositions tout intéressante mais
évidemment qui naissent nous l'espérons
une analyse nous avons devant nous un
danger ce dont j'ai chacun le connais
c'est le séparatisme islamistes en
général mais il peut y avoir d'autres
séparatistes vous pour en discuter
d'ailleurs à l'envi si vous le souhaitez
mais je ne veux pas confondre les deux
et c'est le plus important le plus
meurtrier est évidemment celui pour
lequel nous avons
a intérêt à prendre très rapidement le
réveil républicain dont nous invite à
l'afp le président de la république et
si j'entends vos interventions quasiment
tout le monde ici mais nous souhaitons
le faire dans le cadre de l' équilibre
des principes républicains pour
reprendre le titre du texte notamment du
fait que la loi de 1905 est pas qu elle
derrière elle non seulement 40 ans
d'histoire laïc de notre république
mais surmonta philippe le bel la volonté
que la religion soit une affaire de
l'état et non pas une affaire d'
ingérence étrangère puisque ce que nous
cherchons ici à faire c'est lutter seul
contre le séparatisme islamistes mais
aussi contre les ingérences étrangères
qui ne sont pas identiques
nous pouvons vouloir limiter l'influencé
de l'état turc de l'état algérien de
l'état tunisien de l'état marocain et
d'autres états parfois d état ou de
saxon sur les communautés protestantes
par exemple sous le territoire national
sans penser un seul instant que cette
ingérence dont nous pensons qu'elle est
dangereuse pour la république ne se
confond pas non plus avec l'islamisme
radical ou le séparatisme c'est ce que
fait prises en afrique notamment
lorsqu'il a le courage de mettre fin aux
imams détacher c'est non pas islamiste
que d'envoyer un fonctionnaire de l'état
algérien ou turcs sur le territoire
national ils ne sont pas islamistes mais
ils ne sont pas on va dire dans la
loyauté absolue avec la réplique
française puisqu'ils sont fonctionnaires
de leur pays donc d'abord il ya le
séparatisme islamistes et de manière
générale le séparatisme et puis il ya
elle compterait agences étrangères
premier point nous le faisons
conformément à la tradition donc que la
religion est une affaire française
quelle que soit cette religion c'est ce
qu'a voulu dire philippe le bel au pape
parce qu'il a voulu lever des impôts
notamment
c'est ce qu'on a fait me semble-t-il
aussi avec les juifs de france sous la
révolution
c'est ce qu'on a refait après le
concordat grâce à la république et c'est
ce que nous disons aujourd'hui pour les
musulmans ils ont évidemment toute
liberté en tant que citoyen en tant que
croyants mais c'est une affaire qui
intéresse la république française est
pas un état
étrangers et nous le faisons dans un
cadre qui est celui de la non
reconnaissance dans les jours par
rapport à une autre
et lorsque vous me dites monsieur
présence heures lorsque vous dites que
ce président bah pourquoi embêter toutes
les autres religions mais qu'auriez vous
souhaitez que je fasse que je propose au
conseil des ministres un texte qui
concerne que des musulmans il aurait été
évidemment contraire aux lois de
séparation des églises et de l'état
alors peut-être que ça peut être une
solution politique c'est avant ce qu'on
fait des pays qui n'ont pas la laïcité
française des autrichiens aulnoye
spécifiques
par contre l'islam mais contre les
islamistes dans lequel il part du
principe que l'islamisme politique étant
un dérivé de l'islam je crois qu'on peut
le constater et c'est pas une insulte
évidemment à le faire pour se dire que
si on veut faire le réveil républicain
si on veut éviter d'angélisme et par
ailleurs et de fidèles à la république
et finalement l'histoire de france de
considérer que c'est une affaire
éminemment française que celle de la
religion sans s'immiscer dans le culte
bien évidemment au dans le dogme bien
sûr et que par ailleurs nous voulons
être fidèle à 1905 à sa promesse et à la
non reconnaissance par l'état d'un culte
plutôt qu'un autre nous ne pouvons pas
distinguer ces cultes et donc je le dis
bien sûr que ça peut gêner bien sûr que
je peux comprendre les interrogations
des cultes mais il ne serions pas a
faussement naïf d'abord gens étaient
heureux et l'archevêque de reims sans
doute aussi de savoir permettre d'à
s'appuie ce site et dans la commission
vous même monsieur présents sur site et
le culte protestant ou parfois même ici
j'ai entendu à l'assemblée comme ici des
le culte catholique
enfin les catholiques ont jamais été
favorable en 1950 en 1905
chacun le sait aujourd'hui je comprends
que c'est une loi d' équilibre pour
lequel et se sont inscrits et pour
lequel l' équilibre a été trouvé enfin
on va pas me faire croire non plus que
les cultes heureux en 1905 ont tous
soutenu les parlementaires de la nation
à la république à voter absolument la
séparation des églises et de l'état
chacun sait que c'est pas comme ça que
ça s'est passé ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas faire attention aux
interrogations et aux inquiétudes et
nous sommes là pour les rassurer je
compte évidemment sur le sénat comme sur
l'assemblée nationale pour corriger un
certain nombre de choses et j'ai déjà
fait
beaucoup de compromis par rapport au
premier texte après le conseil d'état
ensuite après discussion avec les cultes
et je les reverrai évidemment avant la
séance publique du sénat je pourrais
modifié d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
dispositions encore ce votre demande
mais on pourra en rediscuter d'ailleurs
sur les dispositions nous avons déjà
modifié mais oui nous assumons le fait
que la loi les général elle s'adresse à
tous les cultes et j'aurais d'ailleurs
dire que les dérives sectaires dans ma
la ministre s'occuper et elle évoque
souvent ce sujet sont souvent aussi dans
l'entrée du culte puisque nous leur
connaissons aucun culte et que nous
devons faire attention à ne pas nous
focaliser sur des cultes que nous
connaissons et méprisés ou ne pas voir
les cultes que nous nous connaissons pas
parce qu'ils ne sont pas aussi organiser
aussi historiquement implantée sur le
territoire national donc voilà monsieur
président bah on est on essaye peut-être
peut-être pas avec la plus grande
efficacité selon vous mais on essaye de
se doter d'armes très forte très dur et
d'être dans le cadre de 1905 et je veux
dire aux sénateurs le rudulier que mais
je peux lui répondre et il verra sans
doute mais bon ce jeu que la loi la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
n'aurait rien réglé dans cette matière
puisque nous sommes bien d'accord sur le
fait que personne ne peut se prévaloir
ni de son origine de sa religion pour
avoir une demande et une exception de la
règle commune
vous le faites par l'intermédiaire de
changements constitutionnels je ne pense
pas qu'ils moi personnellement je pense
pas que ce soit nécessaire
en tout cas pas avec le texte que
présenté par la majorité sénatoriale
même si je peux entendre le débat nous
pensons donc effectivement c'est ce que
nous essayons de faire notamment dans
son article 4 notamment son article 18
que personne ne peut se prévaloir de son
de cette communauté je mets des
guillemets pour imposer telle ou telle
expression parce que je veux dire à
monsieur sur également vous répondant
que l'assassinât de monsieur pâtit
évidemment je ne sais pas s'il aurait
été évitée avec un texte de loi ce
serait bien prétentieux que le dire mais
il a manqué deux choses mais à
l'intérieur
à coup sûr pour éviter que ce matin ce
soir ou demain matin cela recommence
parce que c'est quoi
le mimétisme de l'assassinât monsieur
pâtit c'est un homme s'échine à qui
vient avec un autre faire pression sur
l'éducation nationale notamment la
principale de collège rentrant dans le
collège disant qu'est ce que c'est que
ce voyou je mets des guillemets qui a
voulu imposer un cours sur la liberté
d'expression
je lui a taillé le faire et si ça
continue vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir et que de l'autre côté
mejdina sur la vidéo qu'il avoue
lui-même posté en ligne
il lance une fatwa numérique puisqu'il
considère que ce personnage qu'il cite
en l'occurrence monsieur pâtit était le
responsable d'ailleurs en mentant mais
c'est un autre sujet et a donc donné
l'idée aux terroristes
le vrai celui qui avait le couteau si
j'ose dire de pouvoir passer à l'acte
puisque avait ce qu'on appelle ben voilà
un assassinat a lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais aujourd'hui monsieur sueur je ne
peux toujours pas même si j'ai des notes
des renseignements territoriaux comme
c'était le cas la préfecture des
yvelines
quand je vois sur une note en
l'occurrence que le chef d rt voix sur
une note qu' il ya une pression
communautaire pour voir principal de
collège il n'y a pas de délit pour
empêcher le faire il n'y a pas des lits
pour empêcher une femme d'être qui veut
pas être soigné par un homme et qui la
menace il n'y a pas de délit pourquoi
quelqu'un qui vient le fil à l'accueil
d'une mairie et qui refuse de parler à
un homme ou une femme puisse être
poursuivi nathalie de loi ne permet
aujourd'hui de pouvoir faire ce délit de
séparatisme donc ça recommencerait
l'enchaînement monsieur chenilles à avec
la principale du collège
jusqu'à présent je ne peux pas
intervenir et deuxièmement il y aurait
cette fatwa numérique qui est bien plus
sibylline plus compliqué qu'une appel au
meurtre
nous ne pourrions pas c'est parti vite
pour répondre à la vague on trie qui n'a
rien à voir à 4,24 et j'aurai l'occasion
d'en discuter dans quelques instants
le condamné fait le faire aux tirs et
des réseaux sociaux est donc en tout cas
l'enchaînement diabolique de la pression
communautaire dont nous répondons par
des dites séparatisme et de la fatwa en
ligne pour nous répondons par atik 18
permet au moins pour larmes
administrative d'intervenir et ceci à
retirer le contenu en ligne pour suivre
ce chemin-là soit aussi le monsieur qui
n'a quand on sait qu'il est allé
faire pression communautaire
séparatistes envers le principal de
collège
je voudrais dire donc en même temps à
monsieur le présent sûr que si monsieur
président de la commission des lois le
permet je prenne directement classement
national fera pas revenir au jeu le
tableau comparatif avant après 1900 à
si monsieur prévoit vous l'avez déjà
fait distribuer je vous en remercie et
vous constaterez qu effectivement il y
aura bien des intérêts dans 1905 demain
par rapport aux difficultés
d'aujourd'hui
moi je vous le redis monsieur le
président c'est très fidèle à loi de
séparation des églises et des tas de
dire qu'il ya un lieu cultuel qui doit
être gérée comme telle et qui a des
lieux culturels et que c'est pas même
chose que de gérer la mosquée où le
temple protestant de tourcoing que
l'amicale de boules du quai du halot qui
est très sympathique je vous recommande
mais c'est pas tout à fait à même type
d'association est d'ailleurs rarement
financé par des états étrangers
d'ailleurs le club et le club de boules
de l'udc et du halo et jusqu'à présent
les déductions fiscales
les financements étrangers la propriété
la taxation la comptabilité n'était pas
la même imposition 1905 et 1900 et nous
aurions dû faire ce travail les
protestants l'ont fait ils sont allés
1905 quasi intégralité
voilà les nos amis musulmans doivent
pouvoir le faire pour gérer leurs lieux
de culte ça les protège en même temps
que ça permet à l'état de pouvoir avoir
un oeil et c'est bien normal sur l'ordre
public
m6 ne s'agit pas de s'immiscer dans le
culte alors vous évoquez les immeubles
de rapport
je répondrai donc assis à monsieur le
sénateur en même temps que vous monsieur
le président aujourd'hui nous voulons
être fidèle à 1905 c'est à dire que nous
ne voulons pas subventionner les cultes
j'aurais constaté devant vous qui ne
s'agit pas là d'un principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la république
ce qui a été constitutionnalisées c'est
la non reconnaissance particulière mais
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas de
décision constitutionnelle disons que ce
serait supra législatif que de ne pas
subventionner les cultes
c'est tellement vrai que d'une part
l'alsace moselle plus ces départements
et les territoires pardon pacifique plus
à certains autres territoires
ultramarins
yann permet vous le savez financement de
ministres du culte mais la déduction
fiscale
c'est une forme de financement du culte
public sans aucun doute le bail
emphytéotique
sans aucun doute c'est une forme des de
la propriété des personnes publiques
donc aujourd'hui peut-être que le
conseil constitutionnel va tirer de
notre texte
un principe qui fera les buzzer d'âge
aux présence administrative
mais ce qui est constitutionnalisée
c'est la non reconnaissance sa dalle et
si t'es pas le nom subventionnement il
appartient au parlement de savoir s'il
doit pas changer ce texte le
gouvernement ne le souhaite pas enfin
c'est pour l'instant législatif et pas
autre chose que législatif vous me direz
c'est déjà beaucoup mais ce n'est pas le
bloc de constitutionnalité mais nous ne
voulons pas donc subventionner les
cultes
après tout nous pourrions prendre les
dispositions qui est conforme à celle de
la république au début du 20e siècle
qu'a fait la république elle a
nationalisé les bien d'élise peut-être
qu'il faudrait nationaliser des biens
des musulmans pour être s'assurer de
l'équité et que c'est sûr que ce soit
très patriote et très français puisque
nous serions propriétaires par les
communes imaginons les lieux de culte
musulmans comme on est propriétaire des
églises dans 90% des cas ce n'est pas la
solution non plus de nous en proposer
elle n'est pourtant pas si tu as de
cette solution mais elle est
médiatiquement et politiquement a avoué
le compliqué c'était quoi c'était une
spoliation des biens d'église jadis et
pour des raisons que chacun connaît et
qui a fait naître beaucoup de
difficultés pour ne pas dire plus dans
la république
mais si on ne veut pas subventionner les
cultes monsieur sûr si on part du
principe que nos compatriotes notamment
musulmans n'ont pas les avantages qu'ont
notamment les chrétiens et
singulièrement les catholiques de ne pas
avoir rénové leur église puisque c'est
les communes qui le font et que d'autre
part nous ne voulons pas qu'ils soient
financés par les étrangers puisque nous
avons des dispositions qui prévoient
notamment de connaître et financements
étrangers s'y opposer expliquez-moi
comment les cultes finances ni
subvention n'étant pas ce territoire la
république avant 1905 des propriétés
n'appartiennent pas donc aux communes
contrairement à 90% des collectivités
j'imagine que dans notre belle ville
monsieur le
le président entretenir pour les
catholiques la cathédrale ce serait un
peu de frais avouons le et que d'autre
part nous ne voulons pas qu'il soit
financé ni par le qatar l'arabie
saoudite l'algérie sait quel autre état
ou telle organisation
il faut bien trouver des sources de
financement qui sont conformes à l'idée
de laïcité c'est pas la puissance
publique qui aide et à l'idée du
patriotisme c'est pas les ingérences
étrangères qui décide et donc nous avons
comme idée de revenir à ce qui existait
avant la loi mon et c'était très bien
dit par monsieur sénateurs permis pour
d'autres associations
les associations de 1901 et c'est
d'ailleurs un peu à une contradiction de
votre raisonnement si vous me le
permettez puisque ces permis dans 1900
ce n'est pas permise en 1905
donc voyez on encourage les gens restent
en 1900 puisque là ils ont droit d'avoir
des immeubles de rapport
en 1905 est une forme associative
particulière ils n'y ont pas le droit
et nous disons que les fidèles ont le
droit dans un cadre limité vous avez vu
que le parlement notamment l'assemblée
nationale a souhaité qu'à paix pour
éviter les empires financiers seul à
avoir des immeubles de rapport
et je veux dire aux sénateurs que moi je
me pose la question sur les plus onéreux
ce n'a pas été un arbitrage fait par
l'assemblée nationale mais nous pouvons
être ouverts à une discussion comme
celle ci sans doute que ce sera
difficile de trouver un compromis entre
les deux chambres
je ne sais même pas si la majorité
sénatoriale au sens large fait d'accord
avec vous mais la question se pose avec
les cultes qui demandent les immeubles
de rapport notamment nos compatriotes
musulmans mais pas que ils notent aussi
déductions fiscales plus importantes on
va remettre des crédits d'impôts ce sont
des façons de ces mentionné le culte qui
ne sont pas directs et indirects en tout
cas l'immeuble de rapport elle a une
chance incroyable c'est puis il n'est
pas ce sens a souvent seulement déguisé
il s'agit bien de quelque chose de
totalement privée qui n'a rien à voir la
puissance publique et qui est moins
hypocrite que le bail emphytéotique est
moins hypocrite de la déduction fiscale
je rajouterais à cet argument que
souvent les croyants du culte musulmans
et catholiques qui ce n'est pas à jour
que le faire c'est une population qui
plus que la moyenne des français ne
payent pas d'impôts par ailleurs et ne
peuvent donc pas déduire de leurs impôts
et donc qu'ils font parfois très
généraux à leur église
c'est donc une question intéressante que
de voir comment financer un culte sans
que ce soit la puissance publique sans
sur la puissance étrangère
nous n'avons trouvé que les immeubles de
rapport mais de sauver évidemment prêts
à de nouvelles
de nouvelles idées monsieur le début le
sénateur wadleigh d'ajustement et avec
justesse d'ailleurs posé la question de
l'instruction à domicile qui est une
question compliquée mais fondamentale il
me permettra de faire une réponse
évasive puisqu'il appartient l'éducation
nationale de vous apporter la réponse la
plus complète singulièrement parce qu'il
a été auditionné me semble-t-il par la
commission des affaires culturelles et
que le sénat n'a pas fait le choix de la
commission spéciale mais je respecte
évidemment évidemment le choix
parlementaire qui a été fait ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que lorsque je
reviens de marseille et que je parlais
pas de notre département on le
connaissait mieux voire beaucoup mieux
que moi mais qu'on m'explique et je vais
donner les chiffres exacts qui m'a été
donnée par le recteur de l'académie de
marseille
je ne vais pas tarder à vous les donner
à venir et peluches et qu'on passe de
400 mille trois cent cinquante enfants
en un an qui ne sont pas de l'éducation
nationale on peut penser qu'ils ne sont
évidemment pas tous sous une coupe
islamistes ou sectaire bien sûr on sait
tous qui a une grande partie d'entre eux
qui sont qui ont des maladies dont 50%
dit la statistique éducation nationale
une partie d'entre eux d'ailleurs vive
dans l'instruction à domicile avec des
parents qui leur apporte évidemment
l'éducation qu'il faut et notamment
restruction domicile mais une partie
quand même notamment singulièrement des
petites filles qui sont retirés de la
république et que l'idée des
séparatistes c'est de créer une
communauté de la naissance à la mort qui
n'a rien à voir avec la république et
donc c'est une question très importante
mais j'ai remarqué que vous n'avez vous
n'avez pas vous n'avez pas repousser
vous avez vu je demande et la question
des moyens
ce n'est pas la mairie qui doivent le
faire je voudrais vous rassurer sur ce
point est de mise et les questions la
10e assemblée vous redire à son hôte au
sénat
et deuxièmement c'est mignon la question
des contrôles il s'agit là de rentrée
lors d un grand débat autorisation
déclaration bref de mieux connaître
quand j'étais maire comme vous monsieur
le maire
je n'ai pas lu moi toujours les moyens
de connaître le nombre de petit enfant
qui étaient dans la ville il n'y a pas
de fichier prix là y compris
contrat il ya un fichier la caf est
affichée de cpm et enfin afficher
globale des habitants de la commune et
donc à ce titre le maire qui est chargé
la scolarisation des enfants dans
l'école élémentaire n'a pas les moyens
de ses contrôles une question n'ont plus
d'autre choix que c'est une question
très importante mais fermé au mit
négation celle de porter ce tardivement
madame la rbi a évoqué la question de
l'objectif européen notamment dans la
haine en ligne à la raison oui nous
avons ce travail à faire je pense qu'on
apprendra avec monsieur ou et monsieur
dupont moretti sur la haine en ligne se
serait notamment madame la ministre
peut-être d'évoquer ce qu'elle fait avec
pharos qui a beaucoup été renforcée
madame de la gontrie évoqué la
différence je m'emballe pas sur notre
remarque précédente vous avez
parfaitement raison de la la ça triste
de constater que tout n'est pas dans le
texte comme vous l'avez remarqué je
l'ait déjà évoqué je sais mais sans
doute avoir un texte plus large mais
mais il met sa intérieures portent les
dispositions qui auraient du ministère
de l'intérieur
mais je suis comme vous convaincu ayant
été maire que l'urbanisme a un rôle
considérable quelle politique du
logement de peuplement comme on dit un
rôle considérable qu évidemment les
questions éducatives ont un rôle
considérable que questions d'immigration
et d'intégration un rôle considérable et
que comme dirait le proverbe africain il
faut tout un village pour faire un
enfant il faut sans doute toute une
politique publique pour pour améliorer
les la puissance publique afin d'éviter
le
le communautarisme qui même au
séparatisme vous avez bien raison mais
chacun apporte sa pierre à l'édifice
j'aurais ont souligné la différence
profonde 98 24 l'arctique 24 c les
opérations de police l'article 18 c'est
les fonctionnaires en tant qu'agent
lorsqu'ils sont mis en accusation
personnel notamment dans le cadre
familial ce qui n'est pas un article 24
donc on a vraiment affaire je n'ai pas
vu l'écriture exact proposées par
monsieur daubresse n'a semble-t-il ce
matin mais si j'ai bien compris des
rapports que j'ai pu avoir républicains
comme le sénateur
on est là bien rester dans cette
philosophie mais peut-être que je
préside la commission pourrait mieux que
moi précisé ce qui est adopté ce matin
me semble-t-il mais il s'agit bien de
deux articles différents dans leur
fondement
madame boyer alors j'ai laissé madame la
ministre répondre à votre question parce
que ces articles
je vais vous faire deux remarques la
première c'est que si vous avez écrit il
sans cesse au préfet pour avoir des
nouvelles de vos mariages et que les a
pas répondu c'est normal fall écrit au
procureur je suis comme l'a dit monsieur
le sénateur c'est le procureur qui a une
responsabilité des mariages et pas le
préfet puisque vous agissez madame en
tant qu'officier dans le clan du
ministre de la justice lorsque vous
marier les gens et deuxièmement madame
vous savez je reviens de marseille et je
suis très étonné de ce que j'ai vu dans
certains secteurs delà de la mairie et
quand je vois notamment qu' il y a un
local public
c'est ça tout ne sera pas de la majorité
actuelle je vais le préciser alors je me
suis entretenu avec le thunder de
marseille les yeux dans les yeux comme
on dit et il a été très attentif et j'en
remercie et nous espérons des décisions
qu'un local public à un contrat de bail
avec une association sportive et qui a
un sous bail qui est fait par ces
associations sportives pour un lieu de
culte qui lui est très clairement
soupçonnait plus que ça de
radicalisation et que les services des
renseignements territoriaux que la dgsi
et que les services de police
après de multiples alertes à la mairie
de secteur voit que le bail n'a pas été
résilié
je m'inquiète parfois des discours
nationaux et de la vie locale
pour tout vous dire je suis tout à fait
prêt en parle avec vous si vous
souhaitez et la préfète de police
j'imagine aussi fauchon qu'il faut faire
attention aux attaques ad hominem
surtout lorsque vous
attaquer ça fait trois fois madame la
sénatrice que vous le faites dans trois
commissions différentes
je me permets de vous dire que sur ce
point je suis prêt effectivement à
regarder qui a les actes qui
correspondent à leur parole vous avez
évoqué je crois que monsieur le sénateur
la différence entre le sauvegarde à
l'ordre public et l'ordre public
si j'ai bien compris la question qui
m'étaient posées ça revenait pas
notamment du lieu de culte mais ça
relevait de l'association art et bien ça
votre question c'était pour le préfet en
lien avec le lieu de culte
c'était cette question là merci monsieur
le ministre le lorsque le préfet
reconnaît enfin le préfet a deux mois
pour s'opposer à la reconnaissance du
caractère cultuel d'une association qui
a été déclaré qu'ils aient tous les cinq
ans et il peut s'opposer à la
reconnaissance pour trois motifs dont un
motif d'ordre public et je trouve ça un
peu subjectif
j'entends donc c'est pas sûr
l'association mais simple sur le culte
c'est une l'heure nous mettons ce que
fait déjà la jurisprudence ordre public
vous le savez mieux que personne c'est
une vieille tradition de jurisprudence
administrative
il s'agit pas et je voudrais aussi à
préciser madame benbassa que de dire ce
qu'est ou para culte c'est pas du tout
l'objet vous savez qu'aujourd'hui un
rescrit c'est la mode d'actuels c'est à
dire que il ya un rescrit préfectoral
qui est faire inscrire miss à
l'intérieur pour reconnaître la qualité
que cultuelle non pas en tant que culte
on a pas à dire ce qu'est un culte et je
comprends votre question sa subjectivité
mais en tant que critère qui correspond
à ce que doit être au sens droit al
misrati de vie terne la qualité
cultuelle qui permet notamment de faire
des déductions fiscales de ne pas payer
d'impôt local etc
c'était au sens administratif je dis
vraiment aussi problème la sénatrice qui
était en mission avec tout c'est pas le
préfet qui jugent du culte de ce que
doit être un tout et nous pensons nous
que la jurisprudence administrative doit
d en être légalisés et que
les troubles profonds à l'ordre public
par exemple des ministres du culte qui
répèterai un certain nombre de
dispositifs de discours qui serait de
relative à la haine ou si je reprends
l'exemple qui a été fait tout à l'heure
par madame la sénatrice en disant mais
vous pouvez déjà condamner des personnes
individuellement sans condamner des
collectivités ou des lieux aujourd'hui
c'est pas parce que quelqu'un était
condamnée plusieurs fois par la justice
judiciaire que nous pouvons tirer la
conclusion qu'il faut fermer le lieu de
culte dissoudre l'association
c'est d'ailleurs tout notre problème est
un problème très important notamment
lorsqu'on veut mettre fin les jeunes
séparatistes donc et ne nous a pas
semblé qu'il s'agisse et la subjectivité
mais bien d'appliquer la jurisprudence
administrative egonneau la renault plus
objective puisque nous la mettons dans
la loi mais on pourra en discuter
largement si vous souhaitez dans
l'hémicycle pour pouvoir préciser parce
qu'évidemment nous sommes vous comme
nous comme vous très attaché à la
liberté de culte chante amènerait
peut-être parce que je crois avoir
répondu à toutes les questions et
notamment je voudrais dire à monsieur
bart pour en terminer par là que l'une
des difficultés que nous avons c'est que
les islamistes ne semble-t-il sont
minoritaires dans le pays
bien sûr mais qu'ils ont fait nos pères
médiatique dans le discours sur internet
à coup sûr suffit de refaire
si vous étiez un jeune musulman et vous
cherchez comment faire la prière donc
est ce qu est-ce qui est relève les
prescriptions religieuses vous y verriez
99 et encore je suis je suis je suis je
suis pas large
99 % de contenu salafistes ou des frères
musulmans c'est à dire des choses que
nous voulons que m donc vous avez tout à
fait raison de ce sénateur je partage
votre avis le salafisme ou les frères
musulmans ils sont parfois aussi en
dehors des lieux de culte qui sont
surtout en dehors d'une peluche dans les
associations dans les réunions publiques
parfois dans le prisme politique parfois
souvent sur internet etc
je ne peux pas vous donner tort sur ce
point est-ce qu'on chasserait les
salafistes avec nos dispositions des
lieux de culte pour les emmener vers le
champ politique le champ sociétal champ
social peut-être je vais dire qu'ils y
sent déjà vous me faites compléter des
phrases même des rapporteurs
c'est déjà pas si mal que d'assurer au
lieu de culte musulman
la garantie que ceux qui sont ouverts
sur le lieu
de la république sont conformes aux
principes et aux valeurs de la
république et qu'on peut être tout à
fait musulmans fréquentant la mosquée
sans pour autant être qualifié
d'islamiste parce qu'il ne faut pas
sous-estimer aussi la grande
susceptibilité pour ne pas dire parfois
la grande blessure des musulmans qui
sont confondus par leur part leur
religion en d'autres choses qui ne sont
évidemment pas et personne ici ne compte
fait recette
cette confusion est par ailleurs on peut
être rigoriste dans sa religion sans
être contraire aux valeurs de la
république
moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui donnent
un jugement selon qu'on pratique ou pas
de religion avec 40 degrés c'était
pratique je pense que ce ne serait pas
convenable je peux avoir mon opinion
mais ça n'a pas d'intérêt dans la loi
bien évidemment c'est pour cela que les
dispositions que nous proposons il y en
a beaucoup qui vont rejoindre le champ
associatif et je ferai remarquer
monsieur le président bas que ces
dispositions notamment qui vise à
suspendre dissoudre l'association
son exposition extrêmement nouvelle nous
espérons tous qu'elle soit validée par
le juge constitutionnel et madame la
ministre
le contrat d'engagement républicain est
également extrêmement fort c'est à dire
que le mettons fin à des sans doute
centaines de milliers oserais-je dire
des millions d'euros qu'elle soit versée
par les collectivités locales les
organismes hlm les le pôle emploi la
ceppm la caf
j'ai mis fin à des subventions de la caf
pour des voyages 100% halal c'est ça
existe dans notre pays
pour plein de raisons parce que nous
gaver sans doute une volonté peut-être
de ne pas mettre de la politique
publique partout et je pense qu'il faut
le faire c'est que cet argent public et
bien de lutter dans le champ associatif
en plus du culte pour éviter évidemment
la propagation du salafisme des frères
musulmans
ça me paraît évidemment important je
pense que votre question est évidemment
très bonne et je crois que nous avons
des réponses très forte dans les
limitations du droit d'association nous
l'espérons confirmée par le juge
constitution
merci au cinéma même la ministre
monsieur le président oui assez
rapidement si personne n'y voit pas
d'inconvénient je veux faire des
réponses ce groupe et synthétique parce
que le temps qui nous est imparti je
crois avance mais je suis évidemment la
disposition de chaque sénatrice ou
sénateurs qui auraient besoin d'avoir
des éléments complémentaires d'ici la
suite de nos débats peut-être d'abord
sur la question de la lutte contre le
cyber l'islamisme qui a été évoquée je
voudrais vous dire comme l'a dit à
monsieur mise de l'intérieur que nous
avons considérablement renforcé les
moyens de pharos d'ailleurs au lendemain
de l'assassinât et de l'attentât
terroriste contre le professeur samuel
pâtit je me suis rendu chez pharos pour
faire un retour d'expérience et
constater le travail qui a été mené et
c'est suite à cela que nous avons décidé
avec le ministre de l'intérieur
d'élargir les horaires d'ouverture de
faro c'est de faire en sorte de prendre
l'engagement que vingt quatre heures sur
vingt quatre et sept jours sur sept les
activités de faro soit véritablement
réactive
c'est chose faite nous y avons affiliés
de nouveaux policiers et gendarmes et je
les remercie d'ailleurs pour ce travail
parce que c'est un travail
extraordinairement difficile que d'être
confronté continuellement à longueur de
journée à des contenus terroristes ou
d'ailleurs à des contenus pédo criminel
puisque c'est aussi ce qui est traité
par les services de pharos je voudrais
vous dire que les propos d' apologie du
terrorisme sont par exemple
systématiquement poursuivis
il ya maintenant à des signalements qui
existent par ailleurs nous avons
réactivé ce qui s'appelle le groupe
permanent de contacts au ministère de
l'intérieur qui avait été créée par
bernard cazeneuve à l'époque et qui nous
permet de réunir plusieurs fois par mois
au ministère de l'intérieur les
directions des du ministère de
l'intérieur avec pharos mais avec les
directions des réseaux sociaux parce que
nous sommes aperçus que parfois les
réseaux sociaux étaient longs dans leur
réponse voire se permettait de répondre
aux services de l'état qu'il ne
souhaitait pas apporter l'identification
de telle ou telle personne contrairement
à ce qui était demandé par fars ozon ça
nous semblait important de réactiver ce
dialogue est dorénavant c'est chose
faite
nous partageons d'ailleurs les chiffres
des signalements de pharos lors des
points presse mensuelle que nous faisons
pour formellement
souhaid monsieur ministre de l'intérieur
chaque mois il nous arrive de partager
justement régulièrement les signalements
qui sont faits via pharos afin que
chacun puisse suivre l'activité qui est
évidemment en croissance parce que les
citoyens connaissent de mieux en mieux
le dispositif de pharos nous avons par
ailleurs développer la mise à
disposition d'officiers de liaison dans
des associations qui mènent un travail
similaire je pense par exemple à pointe
contactez nous avons pour la première
fois déléguer un officier de la
gendarmerie nationale et je remercie la
gendarmerie nationale pour cela dans
l'association afin de fluidifier la
possibilité de faire des signalements
qui existent sur les réseaux sociaux via
cette association et c'est absolument
fondamental parce qu'on observe et cela
a été dit à de nombreuses reprises mais
je crois que c'est vraiment important
pour pour permettre à chacun de
comprendre l'évolution de ces phénomènes
on observe que par exemple les jeunes
qui se sont radicalisées ne se sont pas
radicaliser dans la rue où en est en
contact et à la sortie d'une mosquée
mais devant leur écran et parfois tout
seuls dans leur chambre devant leur
écran de téléphone donc ça doit
véritablement nous préoccuper c'est pour
ça que nous avons plus de moyens sur
faro c'est la lutte contre le cyber
islamisme et c'est pour ça aussi que
nous avons créée conformément à inventer
du présent la république une unité de
contrôle discours républicain au sein du
cep dr au ministère de l'intérieur afin
d'apporter des réponses notamment aux
fausses informations qui peuvent avoir
lieu et on voit à quel point c'est
nécessaire notamment suite aux actions
pour dissoudre des groupes comme l'a
fait à mes sioniste de l'intérieur je
pense à la dissolution du collectif
cheikh yacine ou baraka city ou du ccf
ont donné des fausses d'informations sur
les réseaux sociaux
il a été important de pouvoir y apporter
des réponses et rétablir simplement
l'effet de l'action qui est menée en ce
qui concerne la question des mariages
particulièrement des mariages forcés qui
ont été abordés par plusieurs d'entre
vous et notamment par la sénatrice
valérie boyer pour dire que oui nous
avons des chiffres dans le monde nous
savons que c'est en
on 12 millions de jeunes filles qui sont
mariées de force et nous savons d'après
les chiffres de l' ong plan
international ou de l'ol jeger note
braille notamment qu'une jeune fille de
une jeune fille sur cinq pardon dans le
monde est mariée de force avant ses 18
ans et la france n'échappe pas à ce
phénomène puisque les différentes
estimations qui ont théorisé par le
gamme ce qui est une fédération
d'associations qui protège les femmes
notamment les femmes migrantes par
l'ined ou d'autres nous disent qu
environ il y aurait deux cent mille
femmes mariées de force en france à
l'heure actuelle à jour avec ses parents
je le dis parce que il ya des confusions
dans certains chiffres qui ont été
donnés donc pour être clair dans les
chiffres que je partage avec vous on
estime qu'il y à deux cent mille femmes
à l'heure actuelle si je peux le dire de
cette manière très vilaine et grossière
dans les dossiers de stocks entre
guillemets de mariage qui existe il y a
deux cent mille femmes c'est une
estimation basse il ya beaucoup
d'associations en france qui estime que
cette que ce chiffre il est bas et que
du fait de certains
certaines situations notamment le fait
que ce chiffre n'intègre pas par exemple
les demandeuses d'asile où les réfugiés
et bien certaines associations estiment
qu'en fait il y en aurait en réalité
beaucoup plus
moi je partage les élèves qui ont été
relayés ici du fait qu'à l'heure
actuelle il est très difficile pour les
élus et pour les mères d'agir et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que nous avons
décidé c'est ont du coup dans les élus
locaux que nous avons décidé d'amplifier
les dispositifs qui existent voudrais
vous dire également que le nom d' appels
au 39 19 pour des mariages forcés
il est passé de environ 50 appels en
2010 est à près de 60 appels en 2018 six
heures qu'il ya une légère évolution
allez après année pour 2019 c'est la
même chose pour la question des mariages
divorcés
lorsque l'on observe comme pour le
certificat de virginité c'est que très
régulièrement les alertes que nous avons
elles émanent des ong qui a qu'un pas
une ces jeunes filles et qui ont été
alertés par la jeune fille ou par des
copines par l'école etc
du fait que ce mariage allait survenir
et donc ne nous avons voulu renforcer le
fait que ces ong puissent alerter et
puis ce fait est que l'officier d'état
civil puisse donc vérifier l'existence
du consentement qui soit exprimée de
façon de façon très libre par par les
futurs époux donc notre réponse est ce
que nous portons dans ce projet de loi
c'est que le nôtre objectif principal
c'est de renforcer justement le
dispositif de lutte
a priori il était évoquée par plusieurs
d'entre vous mesdames et sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs la possibilité
de mieux sanctionner les mariages forcés
je l'entends nous avons voulu vraiment
pouvoir empêcher ces mariages de
survenir et donc notre volonté c'est de
pouvoir garantir vraiment cette liberté
matrimoniale entre les futurs époux et
notamment évidemment celle des femmes
même si je n'ignore pas que dans le cas
de très jeunes personnes il peut savoir
des garçons aussi qu'ils soient forcés à
cela mais l'immense majorité sont quand
même des femmes et des jeunes filles
donc notre article 17 il renforce le
dispositif de protection du consentement
des futurs époux lors de cette
célébration d'expression du consentement
aussi puisque cette disposition elle
impose à l'officier d'état civil de
pouvoir s'entretenir séparément
avec les futurs époux dès lors qu'il y à
un signalement ou dès lors qu'il existe
un doute sur le caractère libre du
consentement après l'audition commune et
après l'examen des pièces qui sont
apportées et qui sont à fournir à chaque
fois en outre dans cet article il y aura
l'obligation faite à l'officier d'état
civil de saisir le procureur de la
république à des fins d'éventuelles
oppositions un mariage ses conserves des
doutes à l'issue de l'entretien
je voudrais dire que je ne balaye pas
les questions ont été posées par
certains d'entre vous notamment sur la
formation des procureurs c'est un
travail que nous sommes en train de
mener avec le garde des sceaux parce
qu'effectivement une fois que cette loi
est votée il faut que à la fois les élus
mais aussi les procureurs puis s'en
emparer c'est une demande qui nous a été
faite également par l'association des
maires de france quand nous les avons
reçus avec monsieur mise l'intérieur et
donc nous sommes d'ores et déjà en train
de travailler
un guide nous avons confié la
coréalisation à la fédération du gard
qui permet de recenser les nouveaux
droits qui existeront pour les femmes et
notamment pour des migrantes ou des prix
moyens de vente afin qu'elles puissent
bénéficier de tous leurs droits ce guide
il sera traduit dans plusieurs langues
avec l'association women tours humaines
et nous adresserons un guide pratique
aux élus je pense notamment aux au maire
et aux élus d'ailleurs pas uniquement
les maires qui sont dans des petites
communes qui n'ont pas forcément
d'administration qui vont pas forcément
possibilité de se faire accompagner et
grâce à ce guide nous espérons qu'ils
pourront comme nous l'avons fait avec
les forces de l'ordre avec la grille
d'évaluation du danger avoir un guide de
questionnaires et pouvoir mener cet
entretien et pouvoir accéder librement
au consentement donc avec cette fois je
rappelle que lorsqu'il ya un doute sur
le caractère libre l'officier va
s'entretenir et ce sera une obligation
séparément avec les futurs époux et dès
lors que les doutes subsistent il va
obligatoirement saisir le procureur de
la république qui sera formé et alerter
aux fins d'éventuels opposition au
mariage qui nous permettra de marquer
une vraie différence avec ce qui se
passe actuellement
parce que c'est vrai que je dois dire
que plusieurs élus ne manger que
lorsqu'il avait dû alerter le procureur
et bien soit il n'avait pas de réponse
soit il n'y avait pas de faits
suffisants là ce ne sera plus le non
consentement ne sera plus à prouver
c'est l'inversé le consentement qui sera
approuvée je rappelle que c'est dès lors
qu'il y ait un doute ça ne va pas
s'appliquer à l'eau
ensemble des mariages ça va de soi mais
je préfère le rappeler parce qu'on a eu
des questions à cet égard il s'agit pas
d'aller à chaque mariage vérifier le
consentement
il s'agit aussi de faire confiance aux
élus et au discernement de l'officier
d'état civil qui mènent ces entretiens
j'espère avoir répondu comme je le
disais précédemment s'il ya d'autres
questions des demandes de précisions je
suis évidemment et son cabinet à votre
entière disposition
merci madame la ministre alors mesdames
les rapporteurs me redemande quelques
instants de questions madame verrière
puis madame c'est une question très
rapide
monsieur le ministre les associations
catholiques sont des associations
diocésaines qui ont été jugés conformes
à 1905 mais qui ne sont pas des
associations 1905
du coup logiquement ce texte enfin ma
question c'est ce texte
s'applique-t-elle s'applique-t-il à elle
par exemple les immeubles de rapport est
ce que c'est une chose auquel elles
pourront avoir accès mais par contre les
contraintes et notamment sur la forme de
l'association qui les gère doivent-elles
changer afin de l'associer sur 2 cm pour
se rendre conforme à la haute ex telle
qu'on l'écrit voilà ces réunions mais
c'est peut-être avait juste c'est plutôt
une forme d'interrogation pour l'avenir
parce que ce texte
bon on est effectivement souvent
nombreux à penser qu'il faut faire des
choses qu'il faut écrire des choses mais
ne pensez vous pas qu'il faille aller
plus loin d'une manière plus générale on
sait que dans des quartiers c'est plus
difficile que d'autres bernard où j
appelle les écosystèmes qui se sont
construits qui se sont enfermés ne
pensez vous pas qu'une des clés aussi
d'une des clés importante c'est de
réfléchir sur la politique de peuplement
des quartiers aujourd'hui on n'a jamais
travaillé là-dessus y compris dans le
cas de la politique de la ville il faut
obligatoirement se l'avouer
collectivement parce que voilà petit de
la villa n'a pas d'hier moi j'ai
travaillé sur toutes les politiques de
la ville depuis le début elles datent
pas d'hier
nous n'avons jamais travaillé sur les
petits gris peuplement pourquoi parce
qu'on parle de politique de repeuplement
aujourd'hui uniquement par le levier des
ressources
donc arrêtons arrêtons l'hypocrisie du
levier des ressources
parlons de la vraie diversité qui fera
en sorte que les gens vivront mieux sur
une vraie diversité
je pense que c'est aussi une clé sur
lequel il va falloir il me semble je ne
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
travailler avec objectivité avec les
bons mots
si madame
ministre alors sur la première question
est un effet mais je redirai dans
l'hémicycle madame la sénatrice
évidemment que le culte catholique est
considéré comme étant quels que soient
ces associations diocésaines étant bien
sûr une seconde dite 1905 et que toute
disposition notamment positive parce
qu'il y en a pour les cultes dans ce
texte s'applique à elle bien sûr et
j'aurai l'occasion de le redire je vais
écrit d'ailleurs à monsieur le président
de la conférence des évêques de france
et c'est d'habitude bien évidemment je
constate d'ailleurs que des dispositions
dites démocratiques des personnes 905 ne
s'applique pas en tant que tel c'est
d'ailleurs en partie pour ça que
l'église avait refusé en 1905
application puisque évidemment la
société diocésaine la paroisse n'existe
pas juridiquement et il n'y a pas de
bureau qui élisent des mecs puisque je
savais qu'il est désigné par parole donc
certains partis pour ça que mon parti
pour ça que l'église n'avait pas
appliqué 205 avait demandé quelque chose
à part donc bien sûr se sont reconnus
sont reconnues comme tel comme 1905 et
n'ont pas besoin de faire de changements
mais de quelque sorte que ce soit pour
pouvoir rentrer dans les règles édictées
hier et aujourd'hui par la république et
je redirai dans l'hémicycle bien
évidemment et je suis très heureux de
leur préciser madame la sénatrice
vous avez mille fois raison moi je ne
dis pas qu'il n'y a pas de lien entre
immigration et séparatisme je dis que ce
lien n'est pas égal mais bien sûr qu'une
partie des migrations non contrôlée de
gens non intégrés mène au séparatisme
bien sûr que l'urbanisme la politique du
logement
je ne dis pas qu'à un lien égal mais
évidemment contribuer au séparatisme et
bernard hoegy que vous citiez très
justement dans les territoires conquis
de l'islamisme et dans ses ouvrages
précédents évoqué non seulement
l'écosystème mais le fait que partout à
force de concentrer et de n'avoir que
des valeurs des remarques
des marques qui était religieux il au
sens religieux islamistes on se séparer
du culte pour aller dans la société et
que notre travail à nous c'est de casser
au moins pendant des moments de
neutralité l'espace public par les
services publics les collectivités
locales l'état l'entreprise bon voilà on
pourrait parler il manque des
dispositions du code du travail mais
vous savez tous que des les entreprises
aujourd'hui peuvent imposer des
principes de neutralité notamment par le
règlement intérieur et leurs
représentants syndicaux et notre notre
travail à nous républicain c'est à dire
bien sûr vous gardez est votre religion
et vos origines si vous le souhaitez
mais vous rentrez dans une communauté
nationale et qu'il faut qu'ils les
moments de votre journée des repères
qu'il n'est pas que qui ne sera que des
repères religieux évidemment mais je
vous ferai remarquer que c'est facile à
dire elle c'est pas facile à faire
notamment lorsque vous êtes en
responsabilité dans une collectivité
locale
d'abord la loi elle a donné le pouvoir
c'est el alami je pense que c'était une
grand drame pour la république que la
loi là me fait le quadrillage de la dsu
ce qui a beaucoup handicapé et a forcé
parfois les maires à garder des poches
de non mixité pour toucher plus de
subventions publiques
et ça c'est une erreur mais fondamentale
est le deuxième point c'est qu'il a
rendu est la donnée à l'agglomération le
pouvoir du peuplement ça peut
fonctionner parce que à l'échelle d'une
agglomération et projets en revue les
projets de repeuplement permet de leur
équilibre dans une agglomération c'est
tout ce qui est des villes plus pauvres
est il plus riche encore faut-il que les
villes plus riches acceptent la mixité
sociale
parce que moi j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
constater dans les quartiers de
tourcoing et grâce à équipe sous deux
gouvernements successifs nous avons pu
avoir un an rue extrêmement généreux que
les gens voulaient souvent restés dans
leur quartier même le quartier que l'on
peut considérer comme divisible certains
s'en vont mais beaucoup veulent rester
et qu'on doit leur offrir une mixité
sociale et faire venir la propriété dans
un logement à la carte c'est d'abord
gagner at on croise et 92 % de logements
sociaux
92 % de non recevoir une commune une
commune
dix mille habitants la bourgogne avec
leur est quasiment des logements sociaux
de ces failles c'était l'idée d'avoir de
la propriété c'est pas facile de servir
la propriété bien sûr dans ces quartiers
mais par ailleurs il faut accepter que
dans toute nouvelle construction y
compris le centre ville y compris dans
les quartiers plus plus classe moyenne à
dire ça comme ça voire même plus
bourgeois la mixité sociale et pour qui
est la mixité sociale pour qu'une bonne
politique de peuplement face à
équilibrer la population et on sait tous
que aller expliquer qu'on va implanter
désormais dans chaque permis de
construire 25 % de logements sociaux la
serbie et le sait et nous le faisons à
tourcoing c'est facile de les expliquer
à la population l'est encore moins
facile d'expliquer que les gens de
roubaix bahizire on a à bondues à
mouvaux marcq en baroeul et pourtant
c'est ce qu'il faudrait en partie faire
pour mixer la population donc il faut
sans doute un travail très fort sur
l'immigration sans aucun doute mais je
crois que ceux qui mettent à signer
galles ne voit pas que le problème ne
plus large que ça et il faut sans doute
avoir une action très forte pour la
mixité sociale mais ce n'est pas dans le
sénat que je vais dire qu'il faudrait
augmenter le pourcentage de loi sru j'ai
passé je pense que je rentre succès
l'estiment oui je pense que par ailleurs
on voit bien qu'il ya une difficulté
d'appliquer non seulement la rénovation
urbaine au niveau d'une métropole quand
bien même les élus seraient très
volontaires mais surtout de l'accueil de
la politique de peuplement des personnes
que vous déménagez de leur quartier et
je sais pas où construire madame en tout
cas comment obliger de faire construire
des logements notamment sociaux mais pas
que dans les quartiers qui n'ont pas ou
qui en ont peu parce que pour la bonne
et simple raison qu'on peut comprendre
qu'il n'ait pas envie de changer
eux-mêmes leur équilibre et leur
écosystème
si vous permettez cette expression donc
il faut un très gros travail sans doute
vous avez raison mais qui ne peut pas
tenir lieu de ce texte qui n'était qu'un
test de police administrative mais qui
n'est pas un terroriste mais vous avez
bien raison merci madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre merci de ces deux
heures vingt de débats devant la
commission des lois ce soir
[Musique]